I should tell you first about the
genesis of this theory,
I suppose is the right way of putting
it,
um,
when I was about your age,
that was back in the early eighties
or thereabouts.
Um,
and this was particularly true around
1984,
but it was true before that too.
Um,
you know,
every generation has its worries,
real or imagined,
and the primary worry for people of my
generation was nuclear war and you know,
it was a genuine worry.
Um,
at one point,
many years later,
I went down to Arizona to visit an icbm,
a decommissioned icbm nuclear missile
silo.
And I,
the ICBM intercontinental ballistic
missiles were very large rockets,
right?
They flew it,
it could fly halfway around the world,
and it was deep underground and behind
very,
very thick steel doors.
It was light green,
pastel green that everyone seemed to
like in the 19 fifties was like pastel
green star trek console.
That's what it looked like.
And,
uh,
so we went down,
out in the yard,
was in the desert,
out in the yard.
There was a very,
I would say,
magical object,
for lack of a better word,
and that was the nose cone for the IC I
icbm and it was quite big about that big
boat out high pointed,
like the point of a bullet about three
quarters of inch of an inch thick
plastic,
you know,
a kind of a resin and it was designed to
melt on re-entry.
So that was just sitting there.
So that was fairly thought provoking,
let's put it that way.
And then we went into the missile silo,
interestingly enough,
appended to the front of it.
It had been decommissioned under Reagan
by the way,
in the front of it,
there was a,
like a museum with artifacts from the 19
eighties featuring Reagan and Gorbachev
meeting multiple times and it was
staffed by these southern.
These Americans from the south who were
grandparent age and they were,
they were just super friendly and you
know,
they were happy to be in the museum.
It was like going to visit your,
your grandma's nuclear missile silo.
And so it was jarring,
you know,
because it's obviously a
poor tentious place and yet it was
conjoined with hospitality and
welcoming.
It was surreal in that manner.
Anyways,
we went into the,
into the silo and uh,
they ran us through a simulated launch.
So imagine a panel like this made out of
metal except twice as long with another
one of these things at the other end,
16 feet across or so,
basically 19 fifties technology,
but updated.
And then imagine that what you had to do
to launch it was the,
there was a guy with a key and there was
another guy with a key,
and if I remember correctly,
the keys were around their necks,
although I don't think they're restored
around their necks permanently.
But.
And so to launch the missile,
you had to put the key in the lock,
both of you.
That was the safety precautions had to
be to have you put the key in the lock
and hold it for 10 seconds.
And then away the missile goes.
And it wasn't as big.
The missile wasn't as big as the rockets
that went to the moon.
But it was plenty big,
you know,
the silo itself would have easily been
as wide as this room is and perhaps
larger and many,
many stories tall,
you know,
because it was nested under ground.
So they ran us through a simulated
launch,
which was
surreal,
I would say.
And then they told us that someone asked
and they said the keys were in once.
Now they wouldn't tell us when,
you know,
that would have been during the Cuban
missile crisis because we were that
close and we were close again at other
times,
although perhaps not that close.
And there seemed to be another peak of
conflict in 1984 when there was a movie
showed at that time called the day
after,
which at that time garnered more views
than any movie ever had on,
on TV.
And it was a story about the aftermath
of a nuclear war and the people who were
left.
And it was pretty realistic and pretty
frightening.
And it turned out,
as I found out later that that movie
actually was one of the things that
influenced Ronald Reagan to put pressure
on or negotiate with the Soviets.
Depending on how you look at it and so,
well,
and then,
you know,
five years later the Soviet Union
collapsed.
No one saw that coming,
um,
and it really didn't collapse in 1989 in
some sense.
You know,
like a huge machine like that doesn't
fall apart all at once.
It falls apart over time.
And then
at some point it just becomes an
unsustainable and topples and you know,
it's like they lost faith in their
doctrine and,
and,
and for good reason.
You know,
that
the system in Russia,
the Soviet Union,
which was a collection of states,
an empire and the system that was
established in China and the system that
still exists in Korea as a remnant of
the Cold War and systems in Southeast
Asia and in Africa were all predicated
on Marxist presuppositions.
Presuppositions that were Utopian in
nature.
And that
posited a utopian future where property
was held in common and everyone had
enough.
And everyone was called upon to do what
they could write from each according to
his ability to each according to his
need.
Which is a lovely sentiment.
And you can imagine how it would be
attractive even intellectually because
of course other systems,
all other systems produce vast
disparities in income.
It's like a natural law that's actually
governed by.
You can model it
with a distribution called the
peritoneal distribution and the prieto
distribution.
It looks like this.
It doesn't look like a normal
distribution.
A lot of you guys have been told about
normal distributions and how many things
follow a normal distribution.
Most things,
but that's really a limited case.
You can understand that prieto
distribution,
if you.
You've all played monopoly,
I presume at the beginning everyone has
the same amount of money,
will include property,
the same amount of wealth.
And then what happens as the game
progresses and really as a function of
chance.
I mean I know yet you have to use your
head a little bit monopoly,
but the basic rule is just buy
everything you can get your hands on and
then trade meanly,
something like that.
So at the beginning everybody has the
same amount.
And then as you begin to play,
if you had enough players,
you would develop an,
a normal distribution because some
people would win,
see relatively consistently and some
people would lose relatively
consistently.
And so the money starts to be
distributed in a normal distribution.
But the thing about money and the thing
about lots of things is that zero is
involved in zero is a weird place
because if you're playing a trading game
and you hit zero,
then you're done.
And so,
and it's very hard to recover zero and
you know,
it's really hard to recover.
You know,
when you're doomed and monopoly,
you know,
you can tell you've got some resources,
but there's going to be some crisis when
you land on some hotel and you're going
to get wiped out,
you know it.
So there's a point at which you're
headed for zero.
Even if you have something you know and
you might be rescued by luck,
but you know when you're doomed.
So what happens is that as you continue
to play monopoly,
more and more people stack up at zero
and fewer and fewer people have more and
more money.
And when the game is over,
everyone has nothing except one person
and they have all of it.
Now,
the funny thing about that is that in
some sense that's how trading games
work.
You know,
you've got.
You might wonder why is that,
why there is any quality in this
society?
And it's easy to consider that it's
because the society is corrupt and
perhaps no society is ours somewhat or
horribly corrupt.
That's the variation.
There is no society that's without.
It's criminal and criminal element and
fixed element anyways.
Trading Games tend to produce a prieto
distribution so that very many people
have very little and a tiny minority
have a tremendous amount.
That's the one percent that you hear
about,
right?
And you know,
the thing about that one percent is that
that's happened in every society that's
ever been studied.
It doesn't really matter what the
governmental system is and it certainly
handled it certainly happened under the
Soviets,
that's for sure.
And there was a lot of people who had
enough zero,
so they just died.
So you know,
the,
the Utopian dream was completely
unimplementable for a variety of very
complex reasons.
One is that it's very hard to fight
against that distribution pattern when
people are trading because mirror
statistics will do that and then there's
other things that,
and I should tell you as well that the
prieto distribution government governs a
lot of things,
so if you look at books,
if I remember properly last year there
was something like a million English
language books published and I think 500
of them sold more than 100,000
copies,
which is none,
right?
That's none of that 500.
You can be sure that one of them was by
Stephen King and he took half the money
because there's like five authors in the
English language who are at on every
airport,
paperback stand,
occupying the top rung.
And that's massive real estate,
right?
Because it's replicated everywhere and
because they're so prominent and because
there are no names when people are in a
hurry and they just want something to.
They just grabbed that and then more
money goes to those people.
And so you know,
success breeds success and failure
breeds failure and it's not necessarily
linear.
Now.
It's a really difficult thing to deal
with and it's hard on societies because
one of the things we do know is that,
you know,
as you stretch out the inequality you
make,
men particularly on the lower end of the
distribution,
more and more likely to be aggressive.
It's sort of like imagine every man has
a threshold for violence.
Um,
and status is important to men.
Not that it's not important to women,
but it's a different,
it's a different kind of status.
It's status is important to men because
it's one of the things that makes them
marketable as partners to women's what
actually turns out to be quite important
to the men.
Men tend to compete with one another for
status,
hierarchy position and in a really
unequal society.
If you're like a low rung guy then and
you don't have any opportunity to rise
because the society isn't structured so
that there's mobility.
Then the more aggressive guys tend to
turn into criminality and you know,
and so you could say there's a threshold
for criminality and the more inequality
pressure you put on a particular area,
geographic or political area,
the more inequality pressure you put on
it,
the more men slip past that threshold
and into criminality.
And you know,
there's been pretty good studies done of
drug gang in Chicago.
That was the best one.
A sociologist actually went and hung out
with a drug gang for.
He got into it.
I guess the drug gang leader was no,
I wouldn't say necessarily narcissistic,
but that might be a reasonable way of
thinking about it.
And he was kind of happy with the idea
of maybe being a subject of a book and.
And so this guy was able to associate
with them,
got to know them quite well.
And then the housing project in which
the gang was housed was slated for
demolition and the gang broke up and he
got the books because they kept books.
And what he found was the average street
drug dealer,
first of all,
was employed in another job as well.
And was making far less than minimum
wage now,
but the guys further up the chain of
course followed the prieto distribution
and so there was a tiny minority of them
who were raking in a tremendous amount
of loot and the guys at the bottom,
we're just waiting around for the
possibility that they could rise up the
hierarchy and you know,
it's pretty violent game.
So the chances that someone is going to
be taken out is pretty high and then a
little slot opens up for some
opportunistic second rater and perhaps
he can move up the hierarchy.
So the prieto distribution,
governance,
all sorts of other things too.
I mentioned it governs the popularity of
books,
the sales of books,
but it also,
it also characterizes the distribution
of everything that people produce.
So if you think of creative production
of any sort of artistic production,
industrial production,
it doesn't matter.
Almost everything fails
and a few things succeed beyond anyone's
wildest imagination.
Apple's a good example of that.
No,
I mean the iphone,
they have their competitors,
but it's an extraordinarily dominant
product and they rake in billions of
dollars I think.
I don't know if apple is valued at a
trillion dollars,
but it's close to that and that's a lot
of money and I think if I remember
correctly,
it's something like this.
I probably have the figures wrong,
but like the top 40 people,
the richest 40 people in the world have
as much money as the bottom 2 billion
right now.
You know,
it's not like they're stuffing their
mattresses with that money or they have
a skyscraper full of cash.
That money is out in the economy doing
whatever money does.
So you know,
you can't spend $28,
billion dollars.
So.
And sometimes you can even do some good
with it.
You know,
Bill Gates seems to be doing something
reasonable with his money.
But the reason I'm telling you this is
because one of the things you should
know is that this proclivity for
inequality is pervasive among the
creative products of human beings.
It's the case with,
with goals scored in hockey.
My son told me,
and he's a reliable source on hockey
statistics that
if Wayne Gretzky,
if you don't count any of the points
that Wayne Gretzky managed with scoring,
he still had enough points just with
assists to have more points than any
hockey player that ever played.
So you know,
you even at the upper end of of of the
distribution,
there's some person who's hot.
They're so good at what they do and then
there's another person that's so much
better than them that it's not even
comparable and so.
And the benefits flow to people who are
in that position.
And you can understand why I would say
because now let's say you start writing
and you get a book and a rare things.
Very rare things to have happened.
And then some people read it and they
like it.
And then of course it's much more likely
that you'll get a next book.
And if people like that,
while it's even more likely that you'll
get a third book and then people start
to know who you are.
And then because they know who you are.
They phone you up and offer you
opportunities.
And your network grows and it's like
this exponential increase in your reach
and your capacity for production and
more and more flows to you.
And then on the other hand,
if you start to fail and you know,
why would someone fail?
Well God,
you know,
one idea that's very common in our
culture is that poverty is caused by
lack of money.
And that's a really stupid idea because
money is very difficult to handle.
I had clients who were drug addicts and
the worst possible thing that could
happen to them was that they got some
money.
They're just done.
First of all,
you know,
they were hanging around with people who
were little on the sociopathic side.
And so especially if they weren't that
bright and couldn't defend themselves
very well,
as soon as they got money while it was
off to the bar with all the friends.
And you know,
one guy I remember in particular,
you know,
every time he got as his disability
check,
he was gone for five days,
usually fondom in a ditch,
you know,
cause he just go to the bar,
spent every Saturday had on alcohol and
cocaine.
And wake up in a ditch three quarters
dead eventually completely did and you
know,
then he was ashamed and horrified and
repentant and he'd straightened himself
out again.
And then that was all well and good
until,
as long as he was broke until the next
check showed up and then bang the same
thing.
So you know,
it's not like money is necessarily a
good for everyone.
It's hard managed money.
It's really easy for it to disappear.
I mean elderly people have a hell of a
time now because you know,
crooks are contacting them on the
Internet nonstop.
And so just giving people money,
money's like,
it's like pouring water in their hands
is not that helpful.
Not necessarily that helpful.
And then of course contributors to
poverty are well,
it's not so good to have a low Iq.
You know,
people don't like the idea of Iq because
it seems so arbitrary,
you know,
have a high Iq.
Well it's not like you deserved that.
Exactly.
It's your setup that way pretty much
right from the beginning.
It's a very,
very,
very stable.
You can make a high Iq person stupider.
Why?
You know,
not educating them up to the level of
their possibility,
but taking someone who has a low Iq and
trying to raise that.
It's like if you can figure out how to
do that,
well you know,
Nobel prize time for you because people
have tried that a lot and most recently
with those,
you know,
Luminol lumosity games and that sort of
thing and the evidence that those
produce anything other than brilliant
performances on the lumosity game itself
is basically zero.
We haven't been able to figure out how
to see because intelligence is across
domain phenomena and you can get really
good in a single domain by practicing
like mad and what you'd want is to
practice like matt in a single domain
and hope that it generalized to other
domains.
That's the holy grail of intelligence
increase.
It's like,
no,
no one's done it.
People claim it but the claims never
hold up and people have been trying for
a long time to do it and they haven't
been able to do it.
And
differences in Iq really make a
difference.
You know?
I mean,
you guys,
average Iq is probably one slash 25
slash 30 ad at 1:15
you're at the 85th percentile and 1:15
would barely get you going for you.
For Harvard University,
1:30,
you're probably graduate school material
1:45.
You're up there at the range where you
can probably do pretty much whatever you
want.
Although as you get smarter,
the scatter between your abilities
increase.
So you might have a very high verbal Iq
but not be so good at mathematics or the
other way around,
but it's a massive contributor to
lifetime success and I don't know what
to do about that.
I mean why do smart people make more
money?
Well,
they get to where the edge of production
is faster.
So if you have a thousand people and you
rank order them by ICU,
the smart people are going to come up
with new ideas first and they're going
to have more ideas and they're going to
strategize better.
And you know,
with an Iq of 90,
which is 15 percent of the population,
you think about that 15 percent of the
population.
That's pretty much the threshold for
reading instructions and being able to
follow them.
So you know,
and our society is increasingly
sophisticated so it's by no means
obvious,
you know,
the liberals think,
well
hmm,
the society is unfair because there's
unemployment and the Conservatives think
while there's a job for everyone,
but none of them think,
well there are massive,
massive,
massive differences in people's ability
far greater than anyone realizes.
And that poses a structural problem.
I had a client and I got him a volunteer
job,
which is way harder than you think.
You need a police check for example,
like it's harder to get a volunteer job
than a real job.
But I regard them in a volunteer job and
he had to fold pieces of paper letters.
It was.
He worked at a charity.
He had to full pieces of paper in three
so that he could put them inside
envelopes and,
and then the letters which were in a
pile had to be matched with the proper
envelopes,
which we're also in a pile,
but some of them were French and some of
the wrangling.
So the French ones had to be matched
carefully to the French envelopes and,
and then if,
you know,
if there was one envelope out of,
out of order,
well then he had to figure out whether
it was the papers that were out of order
or the letters that were out of order.
And then some of the letters had
photographs attached to them and you
weren't supposed to bend the photographs
but they weren't always in the same
place.
So that meant you had to figure out how
to fold the paper in three a bunch of
different ways without creasing the
photograph.
And then the other thing is,
and I never realized how difficult it is
to put a piece of paper and an envelope
till I watched someone who couldn't do
it and he probably had an Iq of about
80.
You know,
if you met him on the street,
you wouldn't think anything different of
him.
It was normal looking guy had some other
problems.
Um,
I trained him to fold those damn papers
for like 30 hours and he got reasonably
good at it.
But you know,
if you're good at it and you probably
all are,
you fold it and the edges line up
exactly like really,
exactly.
The tolerance is probably half a
millimeter or something like that.
Then you do the second fold and the
tolerance is the same.
But let's imagine that the first full
you,
you're out by an eighth of an inch in
the second full year out by an eighth of
an inch.
So it's a little crooked.
Not means in totally route by a quarter
of an inch.
Then it won't fit in the damn envelope.
So then you kind of crumpled the
envelope when you put it in there and
then it gets stuck in the sorting
machine.
And so he sweated blood trying to do
that job and eventually eventually plan
to fire him.
So imagine what that's like a,
you know,
you can't get a job and then so you get
a job at a charity as a volunteer and a
charity decides to fire you.
You know?
I mean really that's just.
So I talked to the woman who was running
it and suggested that that might be a
little on the devastating side.
I mean,
she had her reasons,
you know,
he,
he was always asking people questions
about how to do his job and you know,
so that meant he was interfering with
the productivity of other people and it
was genuine interference.
I mean,
she wasn't being mean and it was her job
to make sure the place did what it was
supposed to.
So,
you know,
she was between a rock and a hard place.
Um,
he eventually decided that the job
wasn't for him and relatively soon after
that I think it was too stressful and
uh,
he quit.
So that solved that problem except in he
didn't have job,
which of course is a problem.
Um,
it has a happy ending.
This story,
as far as I know,
he,
he got a dog because he was very
lonesome.
And that dog man have not guy trained
that dog.
That was something else.
That dog just think he lost 30 pounds
while he was training that dog because
dogs,
they're,
you know,
dominant.
And he had to have a tussle with the dog
to figure out who was in charge and it's
a lot of responsibility to have a dog,
but he was pretty damn committed to that
dog.
And he managed it.
The things he went through to keep that
dog.
You just cannot possibly imagine.
It's like a,
it's like a,
it's like a surreal.
It was surreal.
Just like the nuclear missile silo.
I mean,
he had people following him around
informing on him because they thought he
was abusing the dog when in fact,
because I watched the dog was clearly
abusive.
Um,
so he got a job helping a woman who
trained dogs and,
and then he had a job.
So Hooray,
you know,
but it was like a miracle fundamentally.
So anyways,
the reason I'm telling you all this is
because there was a reason for the Cold
War and the reason was that there's
inequality and there's different
theories about how to address that
inequality and different theories about
why it exists.
And there was a Marxist theory about why
it exists,
which was roughly something like
property equals theft.
And those who have more have taken it
from those who have less,
which,
you know,
seems to me to eliminate any conceptual
than that.
There isn't a fixed pot of money,
you know,
money expands actually as we become more
technologically proficient.
And lots of people who have money have
it because they've generated a lot of
wealth.
I mean,
Bill Gates is a great example of that,
right?
He popularized computing.
He made it possible for everybody to,
to have access to computing.
It's like,
seems like a good good for him.
You know.
And you could say the same thing about
Steve jobs and maybe you'll be able to
say the same thing about Elon Musk and
you know,
these guys have tremendous resources out
their disposal,
but you know,
they're not like,
they're not bathing in bank notes,
you know,
they're,
you're trying to continue to do things
and they use their money to do things.
And anyways,
the Russians set themselves up under
Marxists presuppositions and tried to
equalize the distribution of property
and to call that catastrophic,
barely scratches the surface.
And I know that you guys probably don't
learn much about this because for some
reason people aren't taught about it,
but
no,
the good estimates are that the Russians
killed about 30 million of their own
people between 19,
19 in 1959,
you know,
and it's,
it's,
it's brutal.
A lot of that with,
through starvation.
You know,
I saw a photograph the other day which I
tweeted,
which is the worst photograph I've ever
seen in my life.
And that's actually saying a lot because
I've seen a lot of really terrible
photographs because I've done so much
investigation into totalitarianism.
This was a photograph that was taken
during one of the early starvation
periods in,
in the Soviet Union were about 3 million
peasants died.
It was a picture of a peasant couple
standing behind a table at a market
selling human body parts for food.
It's like,
and you know,
I have this weird quirk,
which I don't think does me much good,
but maybe helps me understand things
better when I see that someone has done
something extreme.
I learned to do this a long time ago
when I worked briefly in a maximum
security prison.
I try to imagine what I would have to be
like,
what kind of situation I would have to
find myself in to do that and believe
me,
man,
that's a horrifying enter.
That's a horrifying enterprise because
it is actually possible.
No matter what it is that you read about
someone doing and no matter how unlikely
it is that you think you would do that,
it's possible to imagine yourself in
that situation
and that.
Well,
that's enlightening.
That's what I would say.
That's enlightening.
You know,
because one of the things about
enlightenment is is that you get
enlightened by doing things that are
necessary that you really,
really,
really do not want to know.
You don't want to do and imagine
imagining yourself as a perpetrator of
that sort is that tells you something
about the world and that tells you
something about human beings.
But it's a hell of a thing to swallow.
You know,
and in a very well structured society
like ours where were so peaceful while.
Because we have the heat and it always
works and we have electricity and it
always works,
and we have plumbing,
which is a bloody miracle and it always
works.
You know,
it's just one of the things that this
imagination process has done for me is
keep me alert
to the absolute miracle that my life is
every day.
It's horribly cold out there.
You can't grow any food.
You die if you're out there for 24
hours.
If any of this infrastructure was
unreliable for any length of time,
we would be in serious trouble.
And it's never unreliable.
It's so unlikely.
And so here we are with all this
reliable infrastructure and because of
that,
we don't really have to compete with
each other much.
I mean,
some you don't compete for food,
you don't compete for shelter or some
people do,
but not very many.
So it's really easy to think of yourself
as good because,
well,
you're not doing anything nasty,
Danny one.
But you know,
a cynic might say,
well that's just because you don't have
any reason to.
But those reasons have arisen many times
in the past,
and in fact they're the norm,
not the exception.
We're the exception.
This insanely functional society that
we've somehow managed to generate is
it's incomprehensible to me that it
exists.
So anyways,
back in the industrial,
at the end of the industrial revolution,
you know,
the conditions of the worker were pretty
brutal.
I mean,
George Orwell wrote a book called road
to Wigan Pier,
which I would highly recommend.
It's a great book.
And he went up in the thirties,
I think it was the thirties to work to
live with the coal miners up in northern
northern uk.
And those poor guys,
you know,
they had to crawl to work for two miles
down a tunnel that they couldn't stand
up in just to start their shift.
And then after their eight hours of,
you know,
hacking away at the coal walls,
which is rather difficult and dirty and
dangerous.
And of course you get black lung from
it.
So it's also fatal.
And of course they didn't get paid very
much.
So after doing that for eight hours,
then you crawled back,
you're two miles and you didn't get paid
for that.
That was just,
that was just the commute.
And the housing for those people was not
good.
The food wasn't good.
Most of them had no teeth by the time
they were 30,
you know,
I mean,
being poor was no joke.
Even in a place like the UK,
which was relatively well off.
And so there was every reason to be
concerned about the disparity between
rich and poor and poor is the natural
state.
You know,
that in the Western world,
in 18,
95,
the typical person lived on a dollar a
day in today's dollars.
And you know,
that's not uncommon in many places in
the world now.
So there were reasons to be concerned
with inequality.
And you know,
the Russians took one pathway inspired
by Marx and we took another pathway
inspired by John Stuart Mill and John
Locke and the English tradition,
I would say,
of democracy and competed for 70 years.
And things seemed to have worked out
better here.
But it was a hell of a competition.
And there were real differences in
opinion at the bottom of it and those
two systems turned into armed camps.
And that's not over exactly.
You know what I mean?
There's the Chinese,
the whole a hybrid now between communism
and capitalism and hopefully they're
more interested in getting rich than
they are in,
you know,
having a war.
Greed is a good motivator.
A surprisingly enough,
it's kind of reliable.
But anyways,
by 1989,
the Jig was up.
It was obvious that the Soviet system
could not,
was not functional.
There was no,
no consumer goods,
that's for sure.
Even in the main department stores and
in Russia,
in Moscow,
and people just kind of lost faith in
the whole project.
You know,
it became her for awhile.
I don't know if you know about the show.
Dallas Dallas was a soap opera that ran
at night a cereal.
And uh,
it was about these rich Texans who
lived,
you know,
a one percent lifestyle.
And it was the most popular show in East
Germany.
The streets would empty so that people
could watch dallas.
Well,
when you're sitting in your horrible
Soviet architecture flat that you know,
you had to struggle to get with your
informing relatives because one out of
three people in East Germany was an
informer government informer and you
watched Dallas,
you know,
there's a little cognitive dissonance
occurring and so fell apart and quite
peaceful.
He actually,
you know,
there was a war and there was a bit of
war in eastern Europe,
but it fell apart remarkably peacefully.
And so here we are and we don't know
what to do with the Pesky Russians,
but
at least there's no evidence that there
are mortal enemies for fundamental
reasons of axiomatic presupposition and
things are a lot better in the world
despite what everyone tells you than
they were 40 years ago and there's so
much better than they were 50 years ago.
That it's absolutely staggering.
We've lifted more people out of poverty
in the last 15 years that have been
lifted out of poverty in the entire
history of the world before then.
People are gathering economic resources
at a rate that even the wildest
optimists really couldn't dream of
speeding up.
So it's not like we're without our
problems,
but so during that period of time I was
obsessed is a good word with a question
and the question was why would human
beings
produced two and then produce a massive
arsenal of hydrogen bombs and I don't
know what you know about hydrogen bombs,
but they have atom bombs for triggers
and you know,
that's where thinking about,
because an atom bomb,
you know,
hey,
that's,
that's something but a hydrogen bomb,
that's the son that's really something.
So,
and you know,
there's 20 there at,
at,
at the peak of the Cold War and there's,
this is still true to some degree.
There were literally tens of thousands
of these weapons aimed at the Soviet
Union then at the West.
And that was enough to pretty much put
an end to everything.
And that's a dangerous game man,
you know,
and not only because of intent,
but also because of the possibility of
accidental.
Just an accident,
you know,
just,
just a mistake or just someone who's a
little crazier than you might want them
to be.
You know?
And you might think,
well,
no one would want to bring about the
destruction of the world,
but that just means you don't know very
much about stellan because of all the
people who lived in the 20th century who
had power.
Stalin was the most motivated to bring
everything to an end.
There's some evidence that he was
murdered by Khrushchev and his crew and
Khrushchev was the next leader.
And if he wasn't murdered,
he was at least not provided with
medical attention when he was dying.
And,
uh,
there is reasonable evidence that he was
gearing up to invade western Europe and
he didn't really care how much
destruction would go along with that.
I mean,
he'd already killed tens of millions of
people.
He had a lot of practice.
He was good at it.
It didn't really bother him.
Maybe even enjoyed it.
So what the hell?
That's what I thought.
How can it be that we're doing this?
It's so insane.
So then I started to think about belief
systems,
you know,
because you could say that each camp had
its own belief system.
The one in the West was derived.
It had a very lengthy history derived
from the Greeks and the Romans and Jews
and the Christians and and from various
schools of philosophy and from the
enlightenment and all of that,
and then the Soviet Union was basically
predicated on irrational philosophy that
that opposed the axioms that the West
had evolved and each group organized
their societies around that and no,
I took political science for quite a
long time
and the political scientists and the
economists,
they basically thought that people
competed over resources,
but that wasn't a very good answer as
far I was concerned because it wasn't
obvious to me why people valued the
resources they valued.
There is the economist.
Just assume that there's resources that
you value,
but you know,
people can value a lot of different
things.
It's not exactly fixed.
I mean you tend to value food very
highly if you're hungry obviously,
but you know,
there's lots of things that we value and
that we want that seem somewhat
arbitrary,
somewhat like a decision.
So I got more interested in why people
valued things and what it meant to value
something and then what it meant to
believe something and then how it could
be that someone could believe something
so deeply that they would risk their own
death to protect it or at least risk the
death of other people and and maybe on a
massive scale like,
man,
people are committed to their,
to their system.
Now you know,
a system of belief is not just a system
of belief.
That's one of the things that I came to
understand is that it's not appropriate
to make this to psychological people,
defend their belief systems,
but that's not exactly right.
You know,
we have a shared belief system.
Well,
it's sufficiently shared so that here we
are,
we don't know each other.
We're a bunch of primates.
We're in this room and it's peaceful and
no one's scared.
And,
and that's pretty amazing.
And that means that we're all acting out
our roles.
So we're acting out our roles and we
have an expectation with regards to
those roles.
And those two things match.
And that's the important thing.
And we'll talk about that a lot.
It isn't the belief system or the
integrity of the belief system even it's
the match between the belief system and
the actions of the other people within
the belief system.
What you want to maintain is that match.
You want to act out your beliefs in the
world and you want what you want to
happen.
That's good thing.
You get what you want and you validate
your belief system.
Great,
perfect security,
but a lot of that is if we're
interacting even right now,
there's a whole set of expectations that
are governing what we're doing.
Like you don't want me to take your your
little tablet there,
smash it.
That would be shocking,
right?
You wouldn't know what the hell to do,
You'd be somewhere different if I did
that and you wouldn't know where you
were,
and that's another thing to know because
that's a fundamental difference.
There is a fundamental difference
between knowing where you are and not
knowing where you are.
I think it's in some sense the
fundamental difference.
You can think about it as the
distinction between explored an
unexplored territory,
but you have to.
I don't know if you've ever taken a cat
to a new house.
Cats hate that and because in our old
house and maybe in their old
neighborhood,
they've slunk around
at the edges,
checking everything out.
They start out freight afraid.
They check everything out.
They know where to hide.
They know where to.
They knew,
they knew,
they know what,
what's safe and they know that because
they go somewhere and nothing happens
and so then the assuming that it's safe
and they slowly build up a neighborhood
that they're comfortable with.
My Dad used to take the dog for a walk
and then the cat got lonesome and so it
started to follow him and first of all
it would just go along the buildings,
the houses on their route,
you know,
hiding really from predators and after a
while it got kind of comfortable with
that and then it would follow right
behind the dog.
But it had a border.
And if my dad took the dog over one
street too many for the cat,
the cat would just sit on the corner
and,
and you know,
cry like a cap cries.
It was like,
that's it for me,
man.
I'm not going any farther out into the
unknown.
And so the distinction between the
territory that you have mastered and the
territory that you haven't mastered is a
fundamental distinction.
It's the distinction between home and
the strange land.
And the thing about familiar territory
for people is that most of the familiar
territory that we inhabit is other
people because we're so social.
So you can't really think.
It's a weird way of thinking about
territory.
It's not exactly geographical objective
It's territory with a dominance
hierarchy in it.
And the dominance hierarchy has a
predictable structure and you know where
you fit in it most of the time.
And so that when you act out in that
territory surrounded by your people,
then often you get what you want and
you're so thrilled about that because
you just don't want someone acting
radically around you.
Like,
and you know that.
So he walked down blue or and there's
people there that should really be
institutionalized,
but we institutionalize them all so they
could be free and free to be,
you know,
suffering and malfunctioning out on the
street.
That's what the freedom ended up being.
But you know,
you'll walk by someone like that who's
monitoring away to the voices in his
head,
didn't,
you know,
maybe
striking out against whatever it is
that's plaguing him and you will make
eye contact.
You might even go across the street.
You're certainly going to give him a
wide berth.
You're going to keep a distance between
him and you and you're going to hope
that you don't attract his attention
because he's not in the dominance
hierarchy and you don't know what the
hell he might do.
And that's unexplored territory too.
That's another way of thinking about it.
Like we inhabit time and space,
not just space and not just time.
We inhabit time and space and our
territories are spacial.
We're here now and this is safe now,
and it saved partly because of the
physical structure and it's working,
but it's also safe because none of you
are manifesting peculiar behavior,
but if you started to manifest peculiar
behavior,
if you stood up and started muttering or
yelling or maybe attacking someone next
to you,
all the rest of you would freeze first
because then all of a sudden this would
be unexplored territory,
the match between what you want,
which is a peaceful lecture that you
hope has some content,
the match between what you want and
what's happening has vanished and so
then you're not.
You don't know where you are and so then
what do you do when you don't know where
you are?
What do you do when you don't know what
to do?
Well,
if your computer,
you just crash,
but you know what good is that to you?
You're just going to die.
That isn't helpful.
You freeze first and then maybe you
cautiously cautiously attend or maybe
you don't.
Maybe you just keep your damn eyes
averted and you sit there and you hope
that no one notices you.
That's a.
that's a prey response,
right?
That's like a rabbit frozen when it
thinks a fox is looking at it and we
were prey animals for a long time.
There was a cat that they recently
discovered,
a prehistoric cat that had this bottom
single tooth and they found out that a
human skull fit right inside its mouth
and so it could grab you here and Pierce
the back of your skull with its,
with its single tooth.
And that's what it was evolved for.
So you know,
it's under such conditions.
We evolved and we're predators
obviously,
but were tasty predators and so other
things were perfectly happy to eat us.
And so when you're aware you don't know
what to do,
you act like a prey animal and that's
probably what you should do because
maybe if you keep your head down and
shut the hell up,
there will be any attention to attracted
to you and maybe you'll get through it.
You know,
you might decide,
unlikely to intervene and take the guy
down,
but,
but you would be the exception rather
than the norm.
And it's unsurprising.
Okay.
So what I came to understand was that
belief systems,
regulated emotions,
but not exactly psychologically like it
isn't exactly.
It isn't exactly.
And this is sort of like the terror
management theories.
It's not exactly like you have a theory
in your head,
in the theory explains the world and
because of the theory explains the
world.
The theory is what's making you secure.
It's kind of like that.
It's like you have a theory in your head
and the makes you feel secure because it
explains the world.
But the reason that explains the world
is because other people have the same
theory in their head and then when you
both act out the theory,
you both get what you want and it's
that.
It's the coming together of the theory
and the outcome that makes you.
It's life.
Not only does it stop you from being
anxious and often make you happy because
you get what you want,
but it's not just psychological.
You know,
the fact that we do this,
that we cooperate within our societies.
We match our belief systems and then act
them out.
That's the predicate for a productive
society.
So it's actually,
it isn't just that it saves,
saves you from death,
anxiety,
like the terror management theorists
have it.
It's,
it saves you from death and that's good.
I mean,
being protected from death,
anxiety.
Yeah.
Oh good.
That's great too,
man.
But actually not dying.
That's sort of the fundamental thing
that you're after.
And so people have reason to defend
their territory.
If you think of territory that way,
as you think about it as a domain where
the fundamental presuppositions of each
citizen are matched by the behavior of
their coast citizens,
they have every reason to defend that.
And if it falls apart,
it can have mortally serious
consequences.
It's chaos,
you know,
and that chaos doesn't just destabilize
everybody.
Psychologically.
It destabilizes everything.
It can destabilize the currency.
If can destabilize the industrial
economy,
it can.
The lights can go off.
It's like it's not good.
So Hey,
no wonder people protected.
So then I started thinking about what a
belief system was and I realized that a
belief system was actually a set of
moral guidelines
and moral guidelines are guidelines
about how you should behave also how you
should perceive.
And the reason that a moral guideline is
necessary for you to perceive is that
you can't look at anything without a
hierarchy of value.
Right?
Think about it like how many things in
this room could you look out?
There's an in innumerable things in this
room to look at.
There's just all this squares,
the little tiny squares in this fabric.
You could look at those things for til
the end of time,
one at a time,
but you don't do that.
In fact,
if I took most of you out of this room,
there's a very low probability that
you'll be.
You'd be able to tell me what color the
walls were or even if those things were
on the walls.
And the reason for that is that who
cares?
As long as the walls don't move,
colors irrelevant.
And there's no reason for you to
remember it.
It has no emotional significance,
it has no value.
And so what you do instead is,
well,
this is what you're doing.
So why are you here to.
I don't mean in the broad metaphysical
sense.
I mean specifically why are you here
right now?
And I would say,
well,
your students obviously and you're
trying to get a degree and you know,
you believe that that will have some
functional utility.
Maybe you'll be a little wiser and a
little more literate and a little and be
able to think a little better and be
able to write a little better and so
you'll actually be more functional in
the world.
That would be good.
You know,
and,
and maybe you're interested in,
but anyways,
it's,
you're in this particular lecture so
that you can take this particular class
so that you can get a particular kind of
degree so that you could launch your
life and then in your life you're
probably going to meet someone that you
have a longterm relationship with and
you're going to have children and you're
going to partake in this society.
And that's why you're here.
All of those reasons,
similar caneously is why you're here.
And so then that helps you decide what
to look at.
And so what you look at is at the
moment,
or listen to is me,
because in principle I'm the gateway to
that set of accomplishments at this
moment.
And so you focus on me and that's
because you value that.
And so what that means is you can't even
look at the world without a value
structure.
You know,
it's chaos if everything is equally
unimportant or if everything is equally
important.
It's chaos.
And so value system structures the very
way that you perceive the world.
And I don't mean that metaphysically.
There's plenty of experiments that have
demonstrated that,
like the invisible gorilla experiment,
which,
how many of you know about the end of
the invisible gorilla experiment?
How many don't?
Well,
roughly speaking,
what happens is that there are two
teams,
a white team dressed dressed in white,
and the team dressed in black and
there's video of them and the black team
is passing the basketball back and forth
and the white team is passing the
basketball back and forth and you're
supposed to count the Times.
The basketball gets passed back and
forth.
There's only one basketball.
And so,
you know,
you're diligent for whatever reason you
do what the experiment or asks you and
you count the basketball tosses and you
think,
well that's not so hard.
It's like 16.
So you tell them 16 and they say,
did you see the gorilla?
And half of you say what?
What are you talking about?
And the experimenter says,
well let's watch again,
but this time don't count.
I'll sure enough like 30 seconds into
the video and you know,
the players fill the video screen.
It's not like they're 300 yards in the
distance,
you know,
like little ants playing basketball
there,
right?
Filling the screen,
you can see their faces.
Sure enough a minute into the video.
This guy in a gorilla suit and he's not
little and neither is the gorilla suit.
He comes out,
bangs his chest right in the middle of
the screen for five seconds and then
disappears and half more than half.
Actually,
if people don't see that and it's even
worse down.
Simon did another experiment where
you're at a counter,
you know,
at a store and there's a clerk there and
you're talking to the clerk.
And the clerk goes down hypothetically
to get something in,
a different clerk pops up and you'd
think,
Hey,
I noticed that,
but you don't.
And you can even vary the clerk quite a
bit and people don't notice.
So we focus on very particular things.
And the reason we don't notice this
because it actually doesn't matter in
terms of the ongoing,
our ongoing action.
At that point,
the clerk is interchangeable as long as
the entity there acts like a clerk
that's sufficient.
So leave system structure your
perceptions,
value systems,
we're going to call them value systems.
They structure your perceptions and they
also guide your actions because you act
in accordance with your values,
conscious or unconscious.
You have values that you don't know
about because you just don't know
yourself very well.
Um,
the,
you can tell that,
that you have values that you don't know
very well because sometimes you get
attracted to people that you know you
don't perfectly well that's a mistake.
Or you know,
you're trying to tell yourself to study
and you don't.
And you know,
so there's,
you're not really in control of yourself
to any great degree.
Some and the more integrated you are,
the more control you have,
but you know you're kind of a loose
collection of arguing subpersonalities
and they're more or less directed
towards a single goal,
but it depends on how committed you are
to that goal,
how much you've thought it through,
how much you buy into it,
how many of the contradictions in your
world representation you've managed to
iron out and all of that,
so,
but in any case,
it's value systems that government
action and perception and so we're going
to take an existential
perspective of phenomenal logical and an
existential perspective in this course
and phenomenological means that we're
going to.
We're going to base our presuppositions
on the idea that what you experience is
real.
All of it.
We're not really dividing the world into
object and subject that that isn't how
this particular approach works.
It's more like you have a field of
experience.
It includes things like pain,
which is not really something objective
and but it's real.
I mean,
one of the things I've come to
understand is you don't.
You are not required to believe what I'm
telling you.
By the way,
if you have an argument about why some
of this doesn't make sense,
then you know,
follow that sucker because I'm trying to
tell you what I've reached with regards
to bedrock presuppositions and I haven't
been able to put pry bars underneath
them,
but that doesn't mean you won't.
Um,
and you,
you know,
you should try anyways.
Moral System tells you how to act and
what to see and a shared moral system
keeps your emotions under control and
fulfills your motivation leads.
Now,
there's this old idea of David humes and
David Hume famously posited that you
cannot derive in ought from an is.
And what he meant by that was that
merely knowing the objective facts about
something does not tell you how to
implement those facts in your life and
that that's actually a gap.
Now you could say,
and I,
I think this is the case,
that that's actually a necessary
consequence of the scientific endeavor
because one of the things that you're
trying to do as a scientist is to strip
away the value of the object,
right?
Because I don't care what your
idiosyncratic notion of the object is,
I want to know how you perceive the
object such that everyone else will
perceive it at least that way.
And so that takes the subjectivity
completely out of it.
And so it might just be a necessary
consequence of the scientific method
that it doesn't have a morality implicit
in it.
People argue about that.
Sam Harris,
for example,
argues he believes that we can come up
with a scientific morality.
Um,
I,
I don't believe that because I don't
think that you could make rational
judgments about value.
It's too complicated.
It's far too complicated.
It's something that has to emerge.
It can't be.
I mean,
Marxism was supposed to be a scientific
utopia predicated on scientific
principles and all of that.
And you know,
it just didn't work anyways.
So I kind of buy hume's argument.
You can't derive an art from it is now.
That's a problem.
First of all,
it's a problem because you have factual
knowledge,
but you don't know how to implement it.
You know,
it's like,
should you spend money on aids or should
you spend money on cancer or should
spend money on higher education,
how the hell are you going to calculate
that rationally you can't because you
just don't have the information at hand.
It's not possible to,
you know,
I worked for UN committee at one point
and they,
the UN committee had like 100 proposals
for how the world could be improved,
but there was no order to them.
It's like it wasn't that this was more
important than this.
It's like,
Whoa,
that's the end of that.
You know,
you to start with something and so that
means you have to make something more
important than other things have.
Obviously in your life.
If everything is of equal importance,
then you're paralyzed.
Now you know,
it's a truism and probably an
oversimplified one that since the dawn
of the scientific revolution,
a wedge has been driven through the
heart of our society such that the moral
systems that we use to unite us.
So those would be religious systems
fundamentally
have been subject to an intense critique
from the scientists.
And you know,
it's pretty effective critique even if
you have,
even if you've maintained a traditional
faith,
it's like
no,
the scientific onslaught is no joke and
that's a problem as far as I can tell
because and the problem is,
is that you're still left with the
problem of how you should act.
And Nietzsche,
the philosopher Nietzsche,
where he would say that we're running on
the fumes of Christianity in the West
because over it's thousand years of
domination to let's say,
1500 years of absolute domination,
it produced a consensus of morality that
was predicated on metaphysical
presuppositions and that organized
societies and those societies are
predicated on certain beliefs like the
belief.
And really I would say that something
divined inhabits each individual.
You know,
that's sort of presumption that's
embedded in law.
It's sort of the idea that underlies the
idea of natural.
Right,
right.
There's something about you that's so
valuable that even the law has to bow to
it,
even if you're reprehensible,
even if you're convicted in
reprehensible now.
That's man,
the idea that people came up with that
idea.
That's a bloody miracle.
It's,
you know,
because generally speaking,
your proclivity is if someone's been
even accused of doing something,
that general human proclivity is that
even if someone's just been accused of
doing something terrible,
that's enough so that you can stone them
to death or do whatever you're going to
do with them.
Presumption of innocence before guilt,
good God,
of all the things that aren't automatic
that's got a top the list,
you know,
it's.
It's unbelievable that that occurs and
it's interesting to me because it seems
to me that
that presupposition that there's
something valuable transcendent about
each individual.
I wouldn't call that a scientific
presupposition,
but it seems to be a highly functional
right?
I think in that it isn't unreasonable to
notice that societies that have
value the individual and made the law
subject to the individual even with
regards to voting because that's
basically what voting does,
put sovereignty in the hands of the
people.
Those societies actually seemed to work.
Now whether they'll work for the next
300 years,
who the hell knows?
I don't know,
but they've worked pretty well for the
last 500 years,
let's say,
and we've got it pretty good right now
and you know,
I suspect most of you are rather pleased
that the law recognizes your value as
individuals and you take that for
granted,
right?
You think you have rights and of course
the rights that you have,
natural rights are a logical consequence
of your transcendent value and that's
nested in this as niches observation
that's nested in a set of metaphysical
beliefs and his idea was that if you
wipe out,
sorry,
you wipe out the metaphysical beliefs
eventually wipe out the whole system
because you've knocked out the
cornerstone and it might take a long
time for the thing to shake and fall,
but,
but it will now whether he was right or
not.
It's hard to say.
It looks to me like what's happened
since Nietzsche announced the death of
God in say the late 18 hundreds,
is that western society is oscillated
between extremes.
Extremes on the right Germany extremes
on the left and you know,
with,
with the democracies,
at least the other democracies,
democracies managing to stay the course
somewhere down the middle,
but,
but it's not obvious to me that that can
be maintained without the underlying
metaphysics.
And that's a problem because whatever
you might say about the underlying
metaphysics,
it's not true the way science is true.
And that could be okay because there
might be more than one form of truth.
In fact,
I think there is,
um,
I think there's pragmatic truth and I
think pragmatic truth is actually deeper
than scientific truth.
And pragmatic truth is the truth that
enable you to act in a manner that best.
It improves the probability roughly
speaking of your existence and your
reproduction maximally.
That's a Darwinian idea on one of the
things about the Darwinian theory,
this kind of puts it in opposition to
scientific materialism,
I would say,
is that the Darwinian theory is that you
don't have privileged knowledge of the
world and you can actually tell that
because you die,
right?
If you knew enough about the world,
you wouldn't die and you do die,
and so you're an embodied theory of
sorts and that theory is good enough to
get you along about 80 years and
produced some reasonable probability
that you'll have children and that they
all survive.
That's it,
man.
That's what you've managed after 3
billion years of evolution.
It's a good enough solution.
It's a good enough way of acting and we
don't know a better way of acting and
our world conceptions are actually
nested inside the Darwinian system and
they might be predicated on pragmatic
truths rather than objective truths.
Pragmatic truths are truths that have
functional utility and we're alive.
We care about being alive.
We tend to use our theories as tools.
It's possible that our theories are
tools and that they're tools to help us
stay alive.
Now,
I was reading a bit about Camille Paglia
the other day and,
uh,
I've noticed some similarities between.
She's a famous gadfly.
I would say a feminists have classic
modern feminists,
although she would regard yourself as a
feminist,
unbelievably smart.
Like if you want to watch someone who's
verbally who has verbal mastery beyond
belief,
it's you could watch Camille Paglia.
She's,
she's,
she seems a little manic to me.
She can wrap off and argument at a rate
that's just mind boggling and it's very
coherent and you know,
she tends to shred her opponents and
arguments.
He's so brilliant.
Um,
she said something interesting and she's
been influenced by some of the same
people that I've been influenced by it.
She liked this book by Eric Norman
called the origins and history of
consciousness,
which I would recommend if you're
interested in union theory,
Carl Young.
It's a good introduction to union theory
and it's about the development of
consciousness and it's predicated like
young's work and Joseph Campbell's work
and Mircera Elliot is work,
all of which has been criticized or
ignored by the postmodernist predicated
on id on the idea that human beings have
a central narrative
and that,
that central narrative is the dramatic
expression of
the human system of values and that
that's built into us.
It's,
it's,
it's part of our nature.
We have a nature as human beings.
We're not infinitely malleable white
culture,
which is a postmodernist claim and a
dangerous one.
It's dangerous if we have a nature.
Paglia has this idea
that
the reason that you come to university
and you studied the humanities or the
proper reason if you do that,
is not to engage in premature and
destructive criticism of something that
you don't even get understand,
but to learn as much as you can about
art and literature and poetry and drama
and fiction
and religious thinking and this is all a
kind of a.
You think about it as a.
What is that?
What is all that?
It's art,
you know,
culture.
Music belongs in that category and like
what the hell?
What,
what about music?
It's like everyone loves it or almost
everyone.
It's a mystery.
You listened to music and it's very
meaningful.
I mean,
music gets people through some pretty
dark times.
Why it's not obvious,
that's for sure.
You know,
and in most cultures,
music plays a very central role in
identity formation.
And you guys,
I think you'll probably find as you age
that your favorite music will be the
music that you listened to between the
ages of 16 and 20.
It's kind of like an imprints on you and
it defines a maybe that defines a
generation and maybe you know,
in our tribal past,
and this is highly likely
when you were being inculcated into the
tribal culture that was inculcated with
dance and with masks and with music all
at the same time.
So you're invited to participate in this
drama and to take your place in this
drama and to think of that as a
representation of the objective world is
just not right.
That isn't what it is.
It's an invitation to a drama.
Now then the question might be,
well is the drama reel?
And the answer to that is it depends on
what you mean by real.
I think that great dramas are more real
than real.
They're hyperreal there.
They're hyper real because they provide
guidelines about how to act that are
abstract and even perhaps generic but
applicable across an extraordinary broad
range of situations.
So imagine this,
you know,
you get up in the morning,
you do a bunch of things and someone
asks you what you're doing,
what you did and you,
you know,
you tell them while
the first thing I did this morning was
open my eyes and the second thing was
think about whether I want it to go back
to sleep and then,
you know,
I took off my blankets and then I put my
feet on the floor and then I stood up
and I was blinking while I was doing all
this and I was also breathing.
And then,
you know,
I looked for my call and you,
you really want to listen to that guy.
You don't want to listen to that guy.
It's like,
why do you,
why are you telling me that?
I want you to tell me something
interesting.
Well,
what is it that's interesting and why
isn't that interesting?
It's not obvious.
So,
so then imagine the guy actually tells
you a pretty good story and a little
adventure.
Probably he was doing something normal.
Something unexpected happened.
He had to conjure up some new responses
and he settled the problem or didn't
settle the problem.
Yeah,
you're interested in that.
Especially if he settled the problem,
because if he can tell you how when he
encountered some unexplored territory,
he was able to sew it back together,
then maybe you can do that when that
thing happens,
and that's pretty cheap wisdom for you.
It's.
He had to go through all the aggravation
of figuring it out.
No,
you have to do is listen.
You know,
and that's kind of a classic story.
Classic Story.
Roughly speaking is there's a guy or
woman,
doesn't matter,
go on about their life relatively
normally.
Something blindsides them and they're in
a state of chaos.
Chaos is the place.
Chaos is the place that you end up when
what you're doing and the world stopped
matching and the chaos can be of
different degrees.
You know,
you could wake up and find that your
house was burgled and you could wake up
and find that apparent.
Has Your parent has Alzheimer's or some
fatal disease or that you do or that
your whole family was murdered or that
there's a war starting her?
You know there's different degrees of
chaos and I think you can quantify the
chaos by calculating how much of what
you do and expect is likely to be
disrupted by the event now because that
the more disruption in the more
destabilized you're going to be,
which is why if if someone tells you
that you're going to perish painfully in
three months,
it's like that's a bad one.
You're really in an unexpected territory
there.
Nothing that you assumed that was real
roughly speaking in the world is real
anymore.
We like to watch people in their normal
life blindsided by something
experiencing this inter regnum of chaos
where they explore and gather new
information and retooled their character
or retool the world because you either
of those would work as a and then come
out the other side and things are better
than they were to begin with,
or at least as good,
but better is better.
That's a happy ending,
right?
That's a happy ending.
That's a comedy.
Technically speaking,
and so
what you want,
you want your life to be a comedy,
not that it's supposed to be funny
because comedy doesn't have to be funny
technically speaking.
It's just the opposite of tragedy.
Tragedy is when you're going along
pretty well and you get blindsided and
that's that and you know that can
certainly happen.
It happens to people all the time,
but it's a comedy want now.
What I hope to provide you with,
is there a magic code?
You know,
there was a book published a while back.
Tom Hanks was in the movie.
He was a harvard professor who went
around solving symbolic mysteries.
Do you remember what,
what was it called?
The DAVINCI code.
Everyone liked that.
It sold a lot and you know,
it was a little mysteries and it was
full of hints that there was more to the
world than you think and which is
definitely true and that,
you know,
there was a way of getting access to
that knowledge and then it would really
be worthwhile.
And people liked that.
They liked that idea.
And the reason for that is because it's
actually.
It's true.
It's true,
it's true,
like,
like fiction is true,
so okay,
let's go back to the guy who's telling
you about his morning.
Well,
he tells you something exciting.
Well then imagine that 10 people tell
you something exciting and then you
extract out the pattern of them dealing
with this problem from that and so then
you have a.
that's what you do if you're an author,
right?
Because in a,
in a book,
you don't want the book exactly to be
about what ordinary people do in
ordinary times in their life.
It's like you already know how to be
ordinary during ordinary times of your
life.
What?
That's not useful.
You know,
you wouldn't watch a video tape of
yourself.
Imagine you videotaped yourself during
the day and then the next day you
watched that.
It's like God,
who would want to do that?
So what seems to happen in stories is
that they distill,
they distill.
So they watch people,
people watch people and then they tell
stories about what they see,
but they leave a lot out of those
stories.
Everything that's boring hopefully.
And then more and more stories about
exciting things get sort of aggregated
and then maybe a great writer comes
along and write something really,
really interesting,
profound character transformations.
And then you say,
well,
that's fiction.
And then you say,
well that's not true because it's
fiction.
But then then maybe that's not right.
Maybe it's more than true because who
wants the truth?
The truth is mundane reality.
And you've already got that mastered.
What you want is the distillation of
interesting experience.
And you might think,
well,
why is it interesting?
Well,
that's a really good question because
you don't actually know.
And believe me,
you really don't know because you'll be
interested in things that just don't
make any sense at all.
I'm going to walk you a bit today
through Pinocchio and we'll do that more
the next time to,
you know.
But I want to tell you a little bit
about that movie to begin with,
just so you know how crazy you are.
So you know the plot.
How many people have seen the Disney
movie?
Pinocchio?
Okay.
So lots of people.
So that's strange enough in itself that
so many people have seen it and it's
worth thinking about,
you know,
you tend to show your kids that moody
and.
But do you think about the movie?
It's,
you're doing some pretty weird things
when you're sitting there watching that
movie,
man,
first of all,
it's drawings,
right?
And they're low resolution drawings.
You don't care.
And you watch the simpsons or maybe fa
or a.
what's that called?
The the one that's been concentrating on
political correctness so much south
park.
God,
that animation man,
it's just awful,
right?
It's just horrible.
It couldn't be worse.
You don't care like round heads smile a
little bit of shuffling.
That's a person as far as your concern
is just irrelevant.
And if it was higher resolution,
it wouldn't help.
You just need the bare bones,
right?
Dang your perceptions on.
So.
So you watched this drawing that's been
oakeel beautiful drawings,
animated in a sequence.
You don't watching something real,
you're watching a pure construction and
then you think about the plot.
It's like it's completely absurd.
Everything about it is absurd.
It's like,
well,
one of the characters is a bug and he
turns out to be the conscience and so
what the hell is up with that?
And then there's another character is
this puppet Marionette and you know,
somehow he gets free of his strings and
then goes on this adventure and then
which is,
and then you know,
he gets enticed into various nefarious
places by a Fox and a cat and then he
rescues his father from a whale and you
don't even know how his father God in
the way.
Oh,
it's like the last time you see his
father,
he was in a rainstorm and the next thing
that happens is he's in a whale and
you're sitting there thinking,
Hey,
no problem.
This all makes sense.
It's like,
what?
Really?
Why?
How does that make sense?
Well,
the answer is you don't know.
That's the thing that's so cool.
You don't know.
You don't even know what you're
watching,
but it doesn't matter.
You Watch it and you're interested in
it.
You want to see what the hell happens to
this puppet.
You want to see if he ends up becoming a
real boy because
this seems important.
Well,
you say,
well,
let's Pinocchio.
True.
Well,
that's a stupid question.
It's partly a stupid question because
the answer is it depends what you mean
by true
and
it isn't obvious to me what you should
mean
when you
say that something's true and the reason
it's not obvious is because we have this
idea in our society and it's a.
it's a very profound idea and that idea
is that the ultimate truth is scientific
truth at that tells us about the nature
of the world and it does that in a final
way.
In some sense there is no brooking any
arguments about it and the physicists
have got it right and that's why they
can make hydrogen bombs and that's a
pretty good demonstration of their being
right,
but you don't act as if that's true
and you don't.
And you watch things and pay attention
to things in are captivated by things
that aren't predicated on those
assumptions.
And it seems to me that
there is a problem of what the world is
made out of,
but there is a bigger problem and that's
the problem of how you should conduct
yourself in the world.
And that's really what you want to know.
People want to know that more than
anything because you need to know.
It's like,
here you guys are in university.
It's like you don't know what you're
doing.
I mean some of you know more than
others,
but you're at the beginning of your life
and life is very complex and chaotic and
it isn't exactly obvious.
You know,
how,
what kind of relationship you should
form or what sort of character you
should develop or what you're going to
do for a job or how.
What's the meaning of life?
That's a good one.
Well then you know,
people come to university,
at least many of them and that's kind of
what they want to find out now.
Paglia her notion is that you can think
about it this way,
is that articulated knowledge is
embedded in inarticulate knowledge and
inarticulate knowledges.
The domain of literature and art and and
high culture,
let's say,
and it's we sort of know what it means,
but we don't exactly know what it means.
It means more than we know,
and then outside of that is what we
don't know at all and that's an idea
that you developed as well and maybe
Paglia picked it up from you because you
believed that you know,
there was this domain that had mastered
in every domain and then there were.
There was a domain outside of that which
you could think of as unexplored
territory and what we meant unexplored
territory with was our creative
imagination and that what we were trying
to do with our creative imagination is
to figure out how to deal with that
unexplored territory.
We were producing dramas that we could
act out that would help us deal with
what we still hadn't mastered.
And then outside of that,
there's just what we don't know at all.
And Paglia his idea,
and this was [inaudible] idea,
was that without understanding that
surround,
you're too atomized.
You're not part of your historical
tradition.
You haven't incorporated the spirit of
your ancestors who built all this.
You're,
you're just here now and,
and you don't know what to do either and
you don't know how to maintain your
culture and you don't know how to serve
it.
And you know,
you might say,
well why should you serve your culture?
And while I have a hypothesis about
that,
you know,
you can think about this,
I don't know if it's true,
but people ask what the meaning of life
is and it seems to me that meaning is
proportionate to the adoption of
responsibility.
You know,
like let's say you have a little sister
who's like three,
you're going to take care of her.
Like questioning whether that's a good
idea just seemed stupid.
You know what I mean?
It just doesn't seem like the right kind
of question.
It's like,
well obviously self-evidently let's say
that's what you do and you find it
meaningful.
It's like probably,
you know,
interacting with a little kid when we
had,
when I had little kids,
you know,
when they were like two or under,
we took them out to see their relatives
and they were older people and you know,
they watched that two year old like,
like it was a fire,
you know,
every second that that little kid was in
the room,
every single adult was focused on,
focused on,
on him or her.
Yep.
That's something that people attend to
and that's the source of meaning and
what else is a meaningful well,
your family relationships are meaningful
to you and maybe the responsibility that
you adopt as,
as a friend,
that,
that seems meaningful.
Maybe your decision to pursue a
particular career and be of some utility
in society.
You know,
part of that's governed by your desire
to establish some security and get
ahead.
It's fine,
but you're also
playing an integral role in the
maintenance of the structure that
supports you.
And my observation has been that in my
clinical practice is that people just
have a hell of a time if they don't
have.
If they don't slot in somewhere,
you know,
you think I got to go to work at nine in
the morning and you know,
I've got this rigid schedule.
It's like,
it's probably a good idea to be grateful
for that because what I've noticed is
that if people pull out from those
externally scaffolded systems,
they drift,
they get depressed,
they get anxious,
they don't know what to do with
themselves,
you know,
they're kinda like sled dogs with no
sled.
And we're kinda like sled dogs as far as
I can tell.
Beasts of burden.
Like we need a load man.
We need a load.
And the question is what,
what sort of load do you need?
And here's why I think we need,
we need that.
You know,
there's,
I've been thinking about how to figure
out what's real for a long time.
And because I'm an existentialist,
I'm operating under the presupposition
that you can tell what people believe by
watching what they,
how they act.
I don't care what they say,
I don't care what their statements are
about their view of reality because the
correlation,
the relationship between that and their
actual actions is not certainly not
perfect and sometimes it doesn't even
exist.
One thing I've noticed is that people,
no one argues with their own pain.
Everyone who hurts acts as if they
believe that pain is real.
So we could say the ultimate reality is
pain.
That's how people act.
It's in keeping with the claims of many
religious traditions.
You know the Jews are always
recollecting past pain.
I mean the Christian God is crucified
person.
I mean there's a fair bit of pain there
for the Buddhists.
The fundamental maximum is that life is
suffering,
and I'm.
It seems to me that there's a
metaphysical claim.
There are no metaphysical claim is that
pain is real.
Now,
of course it depends on what you mean by
real,
but people act as if their pain is real,
so that's a good place to start.
Now that poses a problem.
Life is a pain.
Life is suffering,
let's say,
and why is that?
Well,
it's because you can be broken,
hurt and destroyed,
and so that
seems pretty self evident and worse,
you know it and that makes people
unique.
Like that's our self consciousness,
right?
That's really what separates us in some
sense from other creatures.
I mean other creatures have some self
consciousness like a chimp can learn to
recognize itself and a mirror and soak
in a dolphin,
but you know,
that's pretty,
that's pretty bare bones,
selfconsciousness,
you know,
real self consciousness is the knowledge
of your borders and not only in space
but in time and as far as I can tell,
human beings are the only creatures that
have discovered the future and that's
really good because we can plan for the
future,
but it's really bad because you know,
the future is finite and that's like
that's a big shock to the old system and
it's the existential burden that
everyone bears and its associated
integrity with suffering.
And so then you think,
well,
life is suffering and it's finite and
that's part of the suffering.
That's part of what you makes you
question the value of existing and maybe
the value of existence itself.
So then what do you have to,
were used as a weapon against that?
Well,
you know,
we talked a little bit about
responsibility.
Now it seems to work,
you know,
the,
the amount of responsibility that you
adopt
with really in relationship to things
seems to increase your meaningful
engagement.
And you might say,
well what's the most meaningfully
engaged activity?
And you might say,
well how about little reduction in the
old suffering?
No.
So you live your life so that you're not
causing undue pain,
especially pointless pain.
That would be good.
And maybe you could even be more useful
than that.
And you could figure out some ways that
some suffering years,
other people's both.
If you're really,
you know,
hitting a home run,
maybe you can figure out some way that
some of that can be rectified.
And that seems to be meaningful in and
of itself.
I mean,
if it's pain that makes you doubt the
meaning of life,
which is perfectly reasonable,
then the cessation of pain,
the cessation of suffering,
the minimization of suffering as a
logical corollary should be the proper
medication.
And so I would say that means that
there's some mode that you can conduct
yourself in that makes you a good
person,
and
part of being a good person is to
alleviate suffering.
And
I don't think you get to question that
actually.
If,
if the suffering itself is making you
question
the validity of your life,
then you can't also say that the
cessation of that is not useful.
I mean you can,
but it's completely incoherent.
You can.
You can claim incoherent things if you
want.
So then I would say these distilled
stories that I'm talking about,
the stories that are written by great
authors,
I'm particularly fond of Dostoevsky
whose,
whose works are he's head and shoulders
above anyone I've ever read in terms of
writers of fiction.
He deals with the hardest questions that
human beings face.
And he,
he has characters on both sides of the
argument.
And there they really lay out the
arguments.
It's not like Dostoyevsky,
you know,
he has got a belief and so he has a
character and that character has his
beliefs.
And that character always wins the
arguments.
It's,
that doesn't happen in the Dostoyevsky
novel at all.
He sets up a character and then he sets
up like three or four antagonists and
those antagonists,
they're not straw man.
They're like iron giants.
They just stomp his,
his protagonist,
you know,
in the whole thing is a war between
these different conceptions of being.
It's amazing to see.
It's amazing to read.
Um,
so you distill these stories,
great authors distill stories,
great storytellers distill stories,
and we have stories that are very,
very,
very old.
Those are usually religious stories of
one form or another particular be fairy
tales because fairy tales,
some people have traced fairytales,
you know,
more than 10,000
years.
And so they're part of an oral tradition
and oral traditions can last for tens of
thousands of years.
And you know,
it's a story that's been told for 10,000
years is a funny kind of story.
It's like people have remembered it and,
and obviously modified it.
It's like the game of telephone,
you know,
where I to tell you something and you
whispered to the person next to you and
so on.
It's like a game of telephone that's
going on for,
you know,
thousand generations and all that's left
is what people remember and maybe they
remember what's important because you
tend to remember what's important.
Doesn't necessarily the case that you
know,
what the hell it means.
You don't know what music means,
but you know that's a stop you from
listening to it.
You don't know,
generally speaking,
what a movie that you see or a book that
you read means not if it's profound.
It means more than you can understand
because otherwise why read it?
Wow.
So the idea is this,
is that were necessarily nested inside
moral systems.
The moral systems are on narratives,
narrative,
dramas of sorts and the moral systems or
what orients us in life.
And the reason to understand them to the
degree that you can is because you need
to know how to live.
Nisha said that if you had a,
uh,
why you could bear anyhow.
And
that's good.
One of the things that the Auschwitz
guards used to do to the prisoners,
and this is very telling,
so at Auschwitz there was a sign that
said work will make you free.
It was a little joke.
Not really a very funny joke,
you know,
it's the kind of joke that you have to
be,
say tannic is the appropriate term to
conceptualize and to dare to,
to just state.
So when our Switz prisoners came to
Auschwitz,
you know,
they're already pretty,
pretty rough shape.
They were in cattle cars.
They'd been separated from their
families.
Everything had been taken from them.
They were transported for a long time.
They were standing up,
the kids were suffocating because there
was no room in the,
you know,
it was so packed in there.
They didn't have anything to eat.
There weren't any toilet facilities of
any sort.
It was like you got rid of 20 percent of
the people just transporting them,
you know,
the ones on the outside of the cars,
they froze to death because of course it
was cold and pretty nasty.
And then when they got to Auschwitz,
the guards used to have this game that
they would play and this is part of the
work will set you free thing.
They would get a prisoner,
they take a prisoner who's already in
pretty rough shape and then have them
carry a sack of wet salt,
100 pounds from one side of the camp to
the other.
And you know,
when you think of a camp,
you think of something like a football
field,
you know,
maybe something that big fences around.
It's like,
no way man,
these were cities.
These were,
there were tens of thousands of people
in these places.
So from one side of the camp compound to
the other,
that was a good hike and that wasn't bad
enough.
They had to get them to carry it back
and put it in the same place.
Now
that's poetic and it's malevolence.
You know,
what you're doing is you're harnessing
the human compulsion to engage in useful
activity and demonstrating how
absolutely futile that is despite its
difficulty,
seems like a bad thing to do.
People need.
It's a parody of meaninglessness.
That's what that is.
And you know,
people need meaning in their because
their lives are difficult.
And so the question is to what end
should you devote your life?
And another question might be,
well,
does it matter?
Matters an interesting word,
a because matter is matter,
but matter is also what matters.
And I would say that what matters is
more real than matter.
At least that's how you act.
And then the question is,
well,
is there something you should be aiming
at?
That's a good question.
That's the question of the meaning of
life.
And you know,
one of the things that supposed to
happen when you come to university is
that that's the sort of question that
should be addressed.
And as far as I can tell,
and this might just be my more cynical
side,
what I see happening to university
students generally speaking,
is that they come in clinging to the
wreckage of their culture and floating
with the pieces.
And those pieces are taken away by
professors who tell them that everything
can be deconstructed and no,
nothing has any real meaning.
And it's like when you're finally
educated,
it's when you're floating out on the
ocean and you've got nothing to stay
afloat with.
It's like,
well then you're,
you're done.
And you congratulate.
And it's like,
I don't see that as useful.
Quite the contrary.
So let me tell you a story.
The first thing I'm going to propose to
you,
and we'll talk about this a lot,
is that you inhabit a story that the
framework through which you look at the
world is actually a story.
And here's the story.
The story is you're somewhere and you're
going somewhere.
I didn't even.
That can be conceptual or whatever.
It's that.
But there's a gradient between where you
are and what were aiming at,
which means no more really than you're
doing something.
Well,
you're sitting there and hypothetically
you're aiming for something better and
so you're in a state of insufficiency.
Oh,
is the DNS sufficiencies change?
And then you're trying to rectify the
insufficiency and you presume that your
current state is less preferable to the
state that you're aiming at.
And then the way that you bring those
two together is sometimes you can do it
through thinking,
but fundamentally you do it through
action.
You do it through acting in the world.
And so that's sort of,
that's sort of the answer in some sense
to the mind body problem.
You have a conceptual structure,
but when you implement it,
you're,
you're implementing it,
not abstract,
but you're implementing it through
action.
And so that's,
that's the basic story.
It's not a very interesting,
but
it's the framework through which you
view the world.
So it's a value laden framework,
otherwise you wouldn't be able to act
and you wouldn't know what to look at.
So it's a value laden framework.
You look at the world through a value
laden framework.
So then we might say,
well,
what is the optimal Value Laden
framework?
That's what we're going to try to figure
out.
Now I told you about the war that went
on between the Communists and the way
Austin,
how that obsessed me.
And so one of the things that I really
wondered about was what was this just an
arbitrary thing?
You know,
like did the Communists,
they had some axioms and we had some
axioms and if you're a moral relativist,
you might say,
well,
who's to say which set of axioms are
better?
Or even who's to claim that you could
say that a set of axioms,
one set is better than another.
That's a moral relative,
this claim and know fair enough.
So I thought,
well maybe this is just an arbitrary
thing and it's going to be settled by
force because that's how you settle an
arbitrary claim between two competing
systems where there's no room for
negotiation.
So I thought about that for a long time.
I wanted to know what the roots were of
the Marxist system and what the roots
were of the Western system.
And what I surmised was that the western
system was actually something that
evolved.
Whereas the communist system was a
rationalist construction that was
imposed and they weren't the same thing.
And so then I wondered,
well,
what's western culture grounded in and
is there any reason to assume that
that's real in any sense?
And so that's what took me into this
study of the underlying stories.
The fundamental stories upon which our
culture,
I believe is based and some of those are
very old.
I'm going to tell you a Mesopotamian
story.
It's one of the oldest stories we know
I'm going to tell you an Egyptian story.
Those are sources of our culture and I
think those stories are grounded in much
older traditions and I think they refer
to something real actually real.
Now,
I already told you that
there are different ways of
conceptualizing real and that my initial
hypothesis,
presumption,
axiom you might say,
is that okay,
pain is the most real,
and the reason I believe that is because
that's how people act.
Now you can criticize that.
You can certainly come up with an
alternative conceptual framework which
the scientists have because they believe
that the most real thing is mattered.
Maybe we need more than one set of tools
to operate in the world.
It's possible.
So now I want to tell you what I think
the fundamental constituent elements are
of stories,
and one of the things that I hope is
that this knowing this will make you
immunize,
immunize you against ideology.
And the reason am because I believe that
the ideologies are fragmentary,
Meta narratives,
and they have their power because
they're grounded in the Meta narrative,
but they only tell part of the story,
but they have power because they're
grounded in the fundamental narrative,
and so here's the fundamental America as
far as the characters,
let's say we're going to say that people
are prone to characterize the world
where social primates,
we're social cognitive primates,
so we tend to see the world through the
lens of a social creature and so and
partly because we're concerned with
acting in the world and the world is
mostly other people.
Then we conceptualize the ground of that
structure for action in
characterological terms.
So the the most fundamental reality is
chaos and chaos is what you don't
understand at all.
You can't even conceptualize it.
You,
you come into contact with it in bits
and pieces.
When the twin towers fell,
when the twin towers fell,
chaos reigned for a few days.
Everyone was shellshocked and that was
chaos.
And Chaos is what you experience.
When your story falls apart,
and that's a descent to the underworld.
That's chaos.
And basically you live in order and
chaos in order is where when you do what
you think you should do,
what you want to have happen happens,
that's ordered,
that's explored territory and chaos is
when you do what you're supposed to do
to get what you want and it doesn't
happen,
and then that place that you're
magically in.
When that happens,
that's chaos and it has different depths
you could say.
It reaches all the way to hell,
and that usually happens when your life
falls apart very badly and you're down
in that chaos and you realized that it
was your fault and that you did
something wrong and that you knew it and
you ignored it.
That's the worst form of chaos.
So there's chaos itself and then then
the next thing is fairly
straightforward.
You could think there's the individual,
the individual exist in culture and
culture is embedded in nature.
Pretty straightforward.
Nature is mother nature.
For reasons we'll get into and culture
is father culture.
And I think that's because the
fundamental dominance hierarchies in
human primates are masculine and that
nature is assimilated to the feminine
because it's all for two reasons.
First of all,
females do the sexual among human
beings.
So they actually are nature from the
Darwinian perspective.
And second nature is the productive
biological force.
And so we've always conceptualize males
and females and we've used that
conceptualization to sort out the world
at large.
It's a metaphor,
but it's not just a metaphor,
you know,
it's reasonable to consider culture as a
judgmental father.
It's really reasonable because you know
your,
you have a group of people around you,
some friends,
some people that watch you work,
some judges,
and that stretches across a very long
expanse of time.
And those people as an aggregate make an
entity that is judging your reputation
constantly.
And it's perfectly reasonable to
personify that because it's like a Meta
person that's watching you.
And so it's a useful metaphor.
There's a metta person that's watching
you.
Well,
yeah,
there is obviously.
So now you could say,
well that's not real.
It's like
it's not real.
The way a scientific truth is real,
it's a different kind of real.
Well,
nature has two elements.
It's destructive and creative.
Obviously there's the beauty of nature
and it's bountiful element and then
there's,
you know,
an awful east mosquitoes and
elephantiasis and cancer and starvation
and all the terrible elements of nature
and then there's culture and culture is
tyrannical because you have to shape
yourself involuntarily even to get along
with other people.
You sacrifice a lot of yourself and
develop yourself,
but you sacrifice a lot of yourself in
that endeavor,
right?
We have to kind of average ourselves out
in order to to live together and some
societies are more tyrannical than
others,
but there's always a tyrannical element.
Do you see that at the university?
You know,
you guys know that to some degree this
is such a big place.
It's easy to feel like a number here and
that whether or not you're here or not
doesn't matter.
Institution doesn't care.
Well,
that's the tyrannical element of it.
Now what does care?
Because here you are and you're getting
educated and all that and so maybe
that's positive,
but it's a.
it's got both.
These characters always have two sides,
you know there's does negative side in
the positive side of nature and there's
the negative side,
the positive side of culture,
and then there's the individual,
so the individual is like standing on an
island in the midst of an ocean.
That's a good
imagistic conceptualization of your
position.
There's solid ground,
it has a limited expanse and outside of
that is everything you don't understand
and you as an individual have a positive
and negative elements as well,
and that's the hero and the villain.
And of course what good is this story
without a hero and a villain and the
villain is the person who isn't acting
like a person should act in the hero is
the person who's acting like a person
should act.
And so you go to movies and you read
books and there's heroes and villains
and to some degree what you're doing is
you're fleshing out your notion of a
villain.
You know you read about 30 villains and
you think,
well,
there's something villainous about the
villains.
That's the central element of Villainy.
Whatever that is,
and you could imagine you construct out
a mega villain and a metta hero and
those are the characters in religious
stories.
Generally speaking,
you know,
in,
in the marvel movies,
there's Odin and Odin has two sons,
right?
Thor and Loki,
thor is like thor is the world redeeming
hero and Loki is the trickster who wants
to bring everything down and you have to
recognize that in yourself or it's
useful too because otherwise you
underestimate.
No,
it's maps of meaning,
positive psych.
It's definitely not that.
Why might you be villainous?
Well,
first of all,
because you can be.
That's a big deal.
You can be.
It's actually an offshoot of empathy.
This is something that took me decades
to figure out.
I figured it out when I was studying the
book of Genesis because in the book of
Genesis,
people become self conscious and they
immediately have the knowledge of good
and evil and I just couldn't figure that
out.
It's like,
what the hell's the relationship between
that?
And then really,
I tell you,
I thought about that like for 30 years
trying to puzzle that out and then I
realized what it was.
If you're self conscious,
you can,
you can conceptualize yourself as being,
you know that you are and you know what
you're like and you know what hurts you
and what does it.
And as soon as you know what hurts you,
you know what hurts her.
And so that's the knowledge of good and
evil that comes along with being self
conscious as this is something that
distinguishes human beings from every
other animal.
You know a lion will eat you,
but it doesn't really want to tear you
apart slowly,
just for the fun of it.
Well,
it eats you.
It just wants to eat you and you,
you know,
you could call that evil.
It sucks,
that's for sure.
But animals are beyond good and evil in
that sense.
But human beings,
man,
we can aim our malevolence and we're
really good it because we can imagine
God,
this would hurt.
And if it hurts me,
man,
it's really going to hurt you.
So.
And you need to know that you're like
that because you are like that,
and if you don't know you're like that,
or if you don't think you're like that,
you're even more like that than you
think because of the people who are most
like that are people who don't think
they're like that at all and you have to
contend with that and that's why in many
systems of thinking the world is
conceptualized as a battle between good
and evil and it's inappropriate
conceptualization.
It's a medic conceptualization and the
culture is the wise king in the tyrant
and that's always the case and you're
always stuck with that because as an
individual with your negative side and
your positive side,
the negative side is the resentful side
that is irritated that the limited
conditions of being and the suffering
that entails and it's arbitrary and
unfair nature and no wonder you got that
side has a case to make.
It's not trivial in in the brothers
Karamazov.
That argument is laid out beautifully.
There's a character Alioscha who's a
monk,
monastery novitiate,
and not really a sparkling intellect,
but a very good person and he has a
brother Ivan and Ivan's a vicious genius
and Ivan just takes silly Osha apart and
partly he does that by telling a story
about that.
Dostoevsky took this from a news story.
The news story was that this mother and
father had taken their young daughter
and locked her in the outhouse overnight
when it was like 30 below and you know,
she stayed out there crying and
screaming and froze to death and Ivan
basically said to Lee Osha,
you know,
a world in which that could happen,
should not be.
That's a good argument.
You know,
and you can multiply that by millions of
examples.
So the part of us that is opposed to
being and resentful,
it's got a point,
man.
The problem as far as I can tell is that
if you act that out,
then it makes what you're objecting to
worse.
Now you might be happy about that and
you might think,
well,
people couldn't be consciously pursuing
that,
but yes they can.
I would recommend a book called Pans,
Ram if you're interested in that sort of
thing.
It's a book written by a man who raped
1200 men and killed dozens and burn
things down to the ground every chance
he got and tried to start a war between
England and the US and who is aimed at
nothing but may have and he.
He wrote an autobiography at the request
of a doctor who had befriended him and
he tells you exactly what he did and why
the story.
Heroin adversary,
adversary order and tyranny,
destruction and creation.
That's the basic landscape and outside
of that chaos.
And so let's take a break.
Here's another way of looking at this
idea.
The individual is the person who pays
attention and explores a masters or who
looks away
and the
the person who inhabits and explored
territory and this is unexplored
territory and so wherever you go,
there's you and to have two halves of
you that you have to contend with and
wherever you are with people,
there's the society with its tyrannical
and beneficial nature and the society in
some senses that match between what
you're doing and what's happening.
It's really important to get that right
and then unexplored territory that's
wherever and whenever.
What you're doing stops working.
And so it's not exactly a geographical
idea,
you know,
because when you think of explored
territory,
you think of geographic landscape like
that,
like the domain of an animal,
you know,
or like your house and you know,
that's,
that's definitely an element of it.
But you know,
if you're in your house and a snake
comes into your living room and you're
in there,
it's like,
well that's an important difference
between your house.
One second to go in your house now and
so your house can turn into unexplored,
unexplored territory at the drop of a
hat,
and that's because we live in space and
time and so the unexplored territory is
conceptual.
It's a conceptual territory and it's
just wherever you are,
when things aren't working for you the
way they're supposed to be and so and
these are permanent parts of view,
the human experience,
which is why I think they are
fundamental characters in our
narratives.
There's always you,
there's some subject of the story and
that subject is an ambivalent person
with many different potentials.
You're always somewhere and with other
people because that's our territory,
right?
I mean we're social beyond comprehension
and you know,
even our primate ancestors,
most of their territory was other
primates and their brains and our brains
are specialized to view the world as an
aggregation of personalities.
It's really important to us and so we
tend to view the whole world that way.
And then unexplored territory.
Well,
that's where you don't know what to do
and but you know,
you do know what to do when you don't
know what to do peculiarly enough.
It's rather nonspecific.
It's this generalized stress response
and so what happens is you freeze
roughly speaking,
if the threat is enough,
then you produce a lot of cortisol and a
lot of adrenaline so that you're bloody
well ready to move quick and whatever
direction you have to and then maybe you
pay more attention and that's what you
do when you don't know what to do.
And the problem with that is you can
stay in that state forever.
Man.
That's kind of what posttraumatic stress
disorder is.
It's like you're just like that all the
time.
And the problem with that is it's very
uncomfortable.
I mean,
you stay like that for any length of
time.
You're going to get depressed,
you're going to develop an anxiety
disorder,
you're going to get old because you're
burning up resources like mad.
You know,
your system is shunting everything to
maintain that state of emergency
preparation and it's exhausting.
It's not where you want to be.
So that's partly why people are so prone
to defend their territories.
They're familiar territory because if
they're familiar territory is invaded or
disrupted,
then they default back to the state of
emergency preparation and that's like
that can unglue you if it's.
If it's profound enough,
you know,
and you guys know this already.
I mean I think people experienced this
most particularly when they're betrayed
by someone they have an intimate
relationship with,
you know,
when they're lied to.
There's other ways,
the collapse of a dream or a vision that
you've been pursuing or an illness or
the death in the family.
There's lots of other ways,
but be trails is a really good one
because if you're with someone for a
long time,
you trust them.
You have a representation of your past,
you have a representation of you in the
relationship,
you have a representation of them,
you have a representation of,
of relationships.
You have a representation of the future.
You get betrayed.
It's like poof.
Even the past isn't what you thought it
was,
you know,
and what about you?
You know,
how clueless are you and maybe not at
all or maybe ultimately gullible.
You don't know.
Is it your fault or you know,
are you so clueless that you just can't
protect yourself or was the person
malevolent in some subtle way that you
failed to detect everything's up in the
air,
not good,
and this idea that human beings traveled
to the underworld and come back.
It's like it's a really useful thing to
understand because we do that all the
time.
Whenever we fail,
it's like whip down into the underworld
for awhile where everything's in chaos
and then maybe we sort ourselves out and
bang,
we're back up and so one way of
conceptualizing yourself is not as order
and as not as chaos,
but as the thing that traverses between
the two domains and that I would say is
the mythological hero.
So I'm going to start talking to you
about Pinocchio a little bit.
Weirdly enough.
I hope you enjoy this and the reason I
want to do it is because I want to.
I want to put some.
I want to bring what I told you
abstractly down to earth,
and then you can start thinking,
well,
does the conceptions that I've
introduced to you,
are they,
are they good for anything?
Did they help?
That's the order.
Descend into chaos,
reestablishment of order.
That's paradise lost.
Profane history,
paradise regained.
It's the classic comedy and that's the
story of life.
And so the question is how do you manage
it?
And so that's a question you really want
to know the answer to.
So you'll go,
you'll pay money weirdly,
you'll line up and pay money to see a
story about that even if you don't even
know that that's what the story's about.
And the reason for that is that actually
part of you does know what the story's
about.
You know,
you have your cognition has multiple
layers.
You understand things that you don't
know,
you understand in ways that you don't
understand.
And you can tell that because,
you know,
we,
we talked about Pinocchio a little bit,
how absurd it is and that it doesn't
matter.
Well
question.
So we've been talking.
Um,
he also is when people don't do what
they expect you to do it in the negative
sense,
something bad happens.
What if the reaction is extremely
positive,
like something that you don't like
winning a lottery.
Does that,
do you also go into the stress response?
So.
So it'd be the same thing.
No,
it's
not quite the same thing.
It's a good question.
And we will address that.
We will address that.
I mean winning the lottery is generally
not a good idea for people,
you know,
because it's just too much.
It's too much for them.
Flips their lives upside down so.
And they tend to at,
at best to return to their original
baseline level of emotion.
But yeah,
something remarkably good.
I mean it's a lot better than something
remarkably bad obviously,
but it still can have that destabilizing
effect.
So it depends on what elements of your
life it disrupts it,
like it's some,
some in some sense you have a map that
you're operating within in the world and
that map is predicated on assumptions of
different sorts.
Some shallow,
some profound when the profound
assumptions are devastated.
Huge chunks of the map or invalidated
and that can happen sometimes when
dramatically positive things happen as
well.
So,
but the fundamental rule is the more of
your axiomatic presuppositions are
disrupted,
the harder it is on you.
You know,
like maybe you quit your job because you
win the lottery.
It's like,
Hey,
I'm off to the beach,
I'm going to drink Margaritas.
So that'll work for about four days.
You know,
you do that for three months,
you're a,
you're a beach alcoholic.
It's like that's a real improvement,
you know,
so it's not that easy.
And often too,
if you take people out of their routine,
you know,
they just flounder.
Their circadian rhythms go.
They don't eat properly,
they don't know what the hell to do,
you know.
So this is often why people have such a
hard time when they retire.
I'm going to retire and relax.
It's like fire relaxed for two weeks I
would die.
You know,
I need something to do.
I need to be engaged in something.
So,
okay,
Pinocchio,
Disney movie and early one a
masterpiece.
And so I'm going to walk you through it
and I'm going to tell you what I think
it means and you can tell me if you
think that that's useful and I'm only
going to do that for about 10 minutes
today because I do want to cover some of
the details of the class.
And then next class we'll continue with
this.
So,
so the movie opens with the opening
credits which are carved wooden signs,
which is like a hint,
you know,
because Japan was a carver and it starts
with this song which was actually quite
a popular song and it's a bit of a,
what would you call it,
I don't think it's,
the poetry is particularly profound,
but it was a song that people liked and
people still listen to.
And um,
it sets the tone for the movie,
which is what music does.
One of the things that's really
interesting about movies,
it's really mysterious is that,
you know,
if you go to a movie,
there's almost always a soundtrack,
right?
If you go to a movie and the reason to
soundtrack it,
it kind of feels empty.
It feels like there's something missing
and you know,
it's as if the music,
you know,
when you go to a movie,
there's lots of things you can't see.
The characters are only partial and you
don't know anything about their
background.
So it's like a low resolution thing.
What seems to happen with the music is
that it provides the emotional
background,
the complex context,
let's say it's like a substitute for the
context and it,
it guides you in,
in your,
in your perceptions of the movie.
It gives you hints about what's going to
happen.
And,
and,
and the funny thing about that is,
is that we just,
we just don't have any problem with
that.
You know,
it's like,
yeah,
of course movie has its own track and,
and of course when there's a dramatic
scene and the music gets dramatic and,
but that doesn't happen in real life.
So you'd wonder why we would accept it
in a movie.
And I think it's partly because we're
willing to accept the amplification of
reality that constitutes a movie.
And in fact,
we find that compelling and music is one
of the things that does that
amplification,
the dramatization,
and that's,
that's acceptable to us.
This song I find quite interesting.
So I'm going to take it apart quite a
bit.
Um,
in some sense I feel foolish doing it
because it's,
you know,
it's a,
it's a childish,
childish song in some ways.
But,
but that's okay.
When you wish upon a star,
makes no difference who you are.
Well,
okay,
there's some mysteries there people wish
upon stars.
That's like a little ritual,
right?
Why do they do that?
Well,
and what exactly is the star?
That's another question because there
are stars that shine in the heavens and
there are people who are stars.
And so
why are people stars?
While they're usually famous people,
right?
There are people that who attract a lot
of attention.
And maybe there are people who have a
lot of talent.
That's another possibility.
Um,
maybe their models,
I don't mean you know,
clothing models,
although sometimes they are,
but there are models for emulation.
That's what being a star means.
That's why people magazine is full of
stars.
It's like they're,
they're like,
they're like heroes brought to earth and
of course you know nothing about them.
All you know is their public persona and
of course they're usually very
attractive and so that allows you to
project upon them all of the things that
would go along with ideal humanity and
so their stars and,
but still why stars will stars Beckman
in the darkness,
right?
And their other worldly.
That's the thing.
That's cool.
They're not of this earth and I mean
that technically because obviously
they're not of this earth,
but I also mean it.
I mean it phenomenologically I mean it
as an element of human experience.
So most of you are urban and so you've
not had the experience of perhaps of the
full night sky,
you know,
and that's really too bad because the
full night sky is one of those
experiences that actually induces all
naturally,
you know,
and no wonder you look up there and
there's just stars everywhere,
right?
You're looking at the edge of the
galaxy.
That's actually,
that's the Milky Way,
right?
It's the edge of the galaxy.
It's like,
wow,
there's the edge of the galaxy and
there's just so many of them and it's
such an expensive.
You're looking into infinity,
you're looking into the unknown,
you're looking beyond yourself,
that's for sure.
And you know,
that produces a sense of awe in people
like looking at the Grand Canyon or
something like that and it's.
You're looking at something that
transcends yourself,
but that feeling of awe,
that seems to be something that's,
that's,
that's a natural part of our response.
You know,
you might feel or when you meet someone
that you regard as particularly
admirable as well because you'll feel
that there's something transcendent
about them.
So here's an interesting thing to think
about.
There are people you admire and there
are people that you don't admire and
that's a clue,
right?
That's a clue as to your value system
and it might be not really something you
can even put your finger on.
It's like if you find this person
captivating,
you find this person at my admirable and
it's,
it's as if there's something inside of
you that's looking for what's admirable,
you know,
assuming that you are and that person
who's admirable has a,
has a faculty,
some faculty that you would like to have
for yourself.
And so there are a model for emulation
and that's part of helping people
develop,
you know,
like little kids often develop little
hero crushes on older kids,
you know,
not that much older,
but sort of the,
the person that's sort of just within
their grasp and then they follow them
around and imitate them and you know,
so they're imitating what they find
admirable.
Well,
the fact that you find something
admirable as a hint,
as to the structure of your unconscious
value system.
And so you could think even as an
exercise,
you could take well what qualities of a
human being do I find admirable?
You have to ask yourself that in a
sense.
You can't really think about it.
There is a difference between asking
yourself a question and thinking about
it,
you know,
because it's more like when you're
asking yourself a question,
it's contemplating,
it's like,
well,
what do I find admirable?
It's question you don't know,
and if you're fortunate and this happens
quite regularly,
an answer will float up from wherever
the hell answers float up and oh yeah,
that's one,
and you can write that down and you get
some idea of what your ideal is,
you know,
and you have one likely and what your
counter ideal is star well,
to wish upon a star is to raise your
eyes above the horizon and to focus on
something transcendent that's beyond
you.
To focus on the absolute we could say to
focus on the light that shines in the
darkness.
Now a stars,
people wear diamonds because they're
like stars or they're like the sun and
they're pure and perfect and the
glitter,
and so there's something about the light
too.
There's something about a source of
light.
It's a source of illumination and
enlightenment and the and the light that
shines in the darkness is a deep
metaphor,
right?
It's,
it's,
it's what you want,
you want a light to shine in the
darkness and so the star has all that
and so people wish upon a star because
they have some intuition that aiming
above the mundane has the potential to
transform themselves.
They make a wish.
Well,
if you're gonna make a wish.
You should aim at something high and
even just aiming
at that is more likely to make the wish
come true.
And this is not a metaphor.
You know,
I have this program which you guys are
going to do called the future authoring
program is one of two assignments.
One is that you write an autobiography,
that's the past authoring.
The other is that you write a plan for
the future.
That's the future authoring.
I would recommend that you get started
on those right now,
like not right now,
but like really soon because they're
harder than you think and some of you
are gonna write like 15,000
words.
You're going to get sucked right in.
This happens all the time.
You're going to get sucked right into it
and so you write an autobiography
because you need to know where you are
and who you are right now because how
the hell are you going to plot a pathway
to the future unless you know where you
are and then you need to write about the
future because you weren't going to hit
something unless he aim at it.
That's for sure.
And lots of times people won't aim at
what they want because they're afraid.
The reason they're afraid is because if
you specify what you want,
you've specified your conditions of
failure.
You know when you fail and it's better
just to keep it foggy.
It's like,
well,
I don't know if I'm succeeding or
failing,
but you know,
I can't really tell while.
Great,
except you can't hit anything you don't
aim at.
And so the future authoring program is
like a.
it's a,
an attempt to have you articulate your
character.
And so as the past authoring program,
who are you and you know,
the pastor authoring program and asked
you to break your life into the parks
and then to write about the emotional,
you know,
the things that you regard as important.
Yeah.
Important events that have shaped who
you are and you know,
you may find that some of those,
some of that writing makes you
emotional.
I would say if you have a memory that's
more than 18 months old roughly
speaking,
and when you bring it to mind it,
it has an emotional impact,
especially a negative emotional impact
there.
It's like part of your soul is stuck
back there.
And I know that's a metaphorical way of
thinking about it.
But what I mean is that,
okay,
the reason that you still experience the
emotion is because you have not solved
the problem that,
that situation faced you with.
It might be a real problem.
Like maybe you got tangled up with
someone who was really bad and that's
rough man,
because you've got to come up with a
theory of malevolence to deal with
something like that.
And that's no joke.
But if it still produces emotion,
it means you haven't solved the problem
and and your,
your brain is still pegging it as
threat.
It's,
it's a part of your territory that you
did not master threat,
threat,
and until you take it apart and
articulation really helps,
that writing really helps that then
you're not going to free yourself from
its grip and that might not be that
pleasant.
I mean this is one of those situations
were doing.
It tends to produce a decrement in
people's mood in the short term,
but quite radical,
three to six months
down the road,
you know,
and it's often the case that you
unfortunately have to do something you
don't want to do in order to progress.
It's very,
very common.
So in the future authoring program asks
you about different dimensions of your
life,
like because you're,
you know,
you can take yourself as a personality
inside your head,
but your nested in systems that
transcend you and they're just as real
as whatever's in your head.
It's like,
well,
what do you need for life?
Well,
that's pretty easy actually.
Some friends,
that's a good thing,
intimate relationship,
that's a good thing.
Family,
you know either the one you're going to
produce or the one that you come from
where people to some degree of love and
care for one another.
That's a good thing to work on.
You need,
you need some plan for your career.
You've got to fit in somewhere that
people regard as important and that
they'll trade with you so that you can
live.
You need something worthwhile to do with
the time that you're not at work and you
need to pay attention to your mental and
physical health and you need to regulate
your use of substances,
which is a strange one,
but alcohol does lots of people in so
it's worth.
It's worth thinking about.
That's why we put it in there,
so then it's like,
okay,
what the hell do you want?
What do you want from your friends?
What do you want from your family?
Or do you want from your career?
If you could have what you want and
that's what the program asks you.
Three to five years down the road,
you get to have what you want.
Now I'm assuming that you're going to
approach this like,
you know,
reasonable adults and not like 13 year
old dreamers.
I think I want the most expensive yacht
in the world.
It's like fine,
but you know,
that isn't really what it's supposed to
be more concentrating on your character
and so then it asks you to write for 15
minutes without thinking too much about
grammar or sentence structure.
Any of that,
but what your life could be like three
to five years down the road if you were
treating yourself like someone you cared
for and you were helping them figure out
what they wanted and then it asks you to
do the same thing in reverse,
which is to think about the ways that
you're radically insufficient and your
faults and everyone knows this.
I think,
you know,
maybe not,
but everyone has a sense of if they were
going to degenerate,
how they would do it.
You know,
some people would be an alcoholic,
some people would be a street person.
It's like there's some doom thing out
there that's got your name on it if
you're particularly in cautious and you
know,
don't and let things fall apart.
So I want you to write about that.
What do you not want to have happened in
three to five years?
And there's psychological reasons for
this.
A one is you have something to aim for
that's a source of positive emotion
because your positive emotion is mostly
generated by evidence that you're moving
towards something that you value.
It's not generated so much by
accomplishing something because when you
accomplished something,
you're just left with the problem of
whatever you're going to do next.
So you graduate from university.
It's like,
you know,
Hooray.
One day you're at the peak of your
undergraduate university career.
The next day you're unemployed and
looking for a bad job at starbucks.
So,
you know,
while you see what I mean is,
it's,
it's that,
you know,
one problem that you solve is replaced
by another problem.
And so the idea that you're going to be
happy when you solve all your problems,
it's like good luck with that theory.
But,
but you know,
if you're aiming at something worthwhile
and you really believe it's worthwhile
and you've thought it through,
you know,
so that you're not weak,
you're not weak,
you've got your damn arguments,
mustard.
Then when you make progress even a
little bit,
you think,
hey,
that's all right,
and you get a little kick,
a little dopamine kick and that's what
you want.
Cause that's where your positive emotion
comes from.
You can use cocaine if you want,
but,
but you know,
that tends to have relatively
detrimental medium to longterm
consequences,
but it activates the same system.
So you have to be aiming at something
and you should be aiming at something
that's realistic that you want,
that you could get,
you know,
like,
not easily because if it's easy,
in some sense you've already got it.
It's got to push you.
And that's part of the pleasure
actually,
because there's two things that you want
to do when you're pursuing something
that's important and one of them is to
get the thing that's important.
But the other is,
is to make yourself better at pursuing
things.
Right?
So,
so you can get both of those at the same
time,
you,
you're aiming at something and you're
increasing your competence.
It's like that's a good deal.
That's a good deal and there's a lot of
intrinsic meaning to be felt in that.
And then the second half of the program,
you,
you write out a plan for how you're
going to do it and how are you going to
keep yourself on track and you're gonna
write about why it would be good for you
if you did this and why it would be good
for your family and what possible
benefits it would have to the community,
you know,
because you want to nail this thing down
and then you want to figure out what
kind of obstacles are going to come up
and how you might overcome them and how
you might keep yourself on track and all
of that.
And we know because we've actually done
a lot of research on this particular
program that if university students do
this and this is more true,
if they're not too well oriented to
begin with.
If University students do this,
they're about 25 percent less likely to
drop out,
which is lot and about their grade point
average increases about 20 percent.
So Hooray for that,
you know,
because you never know when you develop
an intervention,
if it's gonna work,
there's also evidence but not from my
lab.
That doing such things improves your
physical health and I think the reason
for that is is that you know when you go
over your autobiography and you scour
out those negative places that you're
sort of dragging along with you,
it lowers your overall stress load
because your brain is kind of.
I think it's calculating how dangerous
the world is by attending to the ratio
of successes to failures that you've had
in your life.
Something like that.
And so you know,
if there are holes in your map that you
could still fall through,
then your brain regards the territory
still as a bit on the dangerous side and
then you more prepared for emergency
action and that's hard on you.
So you want to go back there and fix up
those
experiences is to the degree that you
can.
Now those are going to be peer rated.
Now that's complicated,
but here's,
here's how you do it,
right?
The thing so that you have written it
for you and then take everything out
that you're not comfortable sharing with
other people and so there's a couple of
reasons I do it that way.
One is just that there's just no other
way to do it because if I want to do
this with you,
the grading load is too high to do it.
So I thought,
well,
it's still worth doing and because this
is a class about narrative and about
self narrative,
it's the right thing to do and most of
you are graduating soon and it's like
it's a helpful.
I think you'll find it very helpful.
That's what students report and so
you'll each read three people will read
each of your
offerings and give you a grade and then
you get the average of the best two
grades and they're.
They're supposed to provide you with
constructive feedback and constructive
feedback is sort of mostly what did you
do?
Right?
You know,
and maybe some hints about where you can
flesh it out.
And all that,
but so that's that.
And you need to write an essay.
Uh,
this is all detailed on the,
uh,
on the website and that's the website.
If you go to Jordan Peterson.com
on the left,
there's classes,
if he clicked classes you get a bunch of
tabs and one of the towns is psych for
34 and that's obviously this class.
And so the,
there's some extra readings on there and
a list of how we're going to go through
the course.
The dates aren't right.
I gotta update it and I haven't finished
that yet,
but the rest of it's pretty much the way
it is.
This writing program is an online
program and it,
it guides you through the process of
doing it,
but really I would really recommend that
you start like this week because it also
works better if you do it over time.
And it seems like in bursts of writing,
you know,
and to sleep in between episodes because
that's when your brain consolidates its
new information.
And I would say do it meditatively,
you know,
ask yourself,
ask yourself.
It's a different way of.
It's really funny what happens when you
ask yourself questions because part of
you will answer and you don't know what
the answer will be,
but an answer comes almost always and
you know,
like you think,
well what,
what happened to me when I was six
around six that was important and
through some mysterious process,
perhaps a memory will come to mind.
So there's a test.
So there's these two side mounts plus
the essay.
The essay can be in anything you want
that's related to the class.
You have to make the case that it's
related to the class.
So it's an opportunity to,
you know,
to write about something you want to
write about
and there's a final exam and the final
exam,
if you read the book and you come to the
classes,
do you won't have any problem with the
final exam because it's not,
it's not tricky.
It's just a survey of what we've gone
through.
And so I did that.
I didn't have that to begin with.
But you know,
you need a carrot and a stick because
you guys are busy and you know,
you're going to treat outage and do the
things that are crucial and perhaps not
the things that aren't and no wonder.
So I had to make this crucial because
otherwise you won't read it and that's
partly because it's hard and so,
but hopefully the course lectures will
help guide you through it.
And uh,
that's about that.
So I'm going to tell you a bunch of
stories and I'm going to try to explain
what they mean.
And what I hope will happen is that the
world of narrative will open up for you
and that and like I found that
incredibly useful.
It's incredibly useful to understand
these things.
It situates you better.
And it also helps you see what people
tell me about this course frequently is
that
it's something like that.
They already knew what I'm telling them,
but they didn't know that they knew it.
So it makes sense.
It clicks,
it clicks.
And you know,
to me what that means is that you have
the information represented in you in an
action,
in your procedures and your habits and
in your perceptual structures.
It's implicit,
it's the implicit you.
And then
I can articulate in part what that
implicit you is and it fits.
Click.
Oh yeah,
that's what I'm like.
That's what people are like,
that's where people are like.
And so well,
if any of that happened today during
this lecture to you,
well then that's a good sign that you
might,
you know,
benefit from the course.
And if it didn't,
well you could try one more lecture and
see what happens.
So,
but you know,
this is sort of what the course is like.
And if that's what you want,
then this is where you get it.
Good to see all of you.
And I guess we're done right.